hey guys and welcome to a brand new
tutorial series so in this series I'm
gonna be teaching you Java from the
beginning so starting at the absolute
basic setting up an environment how to
create variables methods like all that
stuff and then move it all the way up
into the advanced stuff this is a
beginner tutorial series so I'm gonna
treat this as if you have never learned
any programming language before okay so
let's go ahead and get started the first
thing we need to do is download a IDE
and this is where we're gonna be writing
our java code okay so it's called
eclipse this is what I'm gonna use use
whatever you want but if you're a
beginner I recommend you just follow
along with this because the some of the
things I'm gonna do are specific to
eclipse so go to this link it's in the
description down below and just click on
download and then obviously 32 or 64-bit
I recommend 64-bit as most of you
probably have a 64-bit machine once you
download this if we go sorry I've
already got an open here but if we go to
our downloads we will see that it should
give us something like this double click
on it wait for this to boot up might
take a second ok it's going it's going
let's see and once we're in here we're
simply going to select Eclipse IDE for
Java developers we don't need to be
using any of this other stuff just this
one right here okay so we're gonna
install this I already have it installed
so I'm not going to do that now it is
gonna ask you for a project directory
something like that so if it asked you
for that just choose wherever on your
computer it doesn't really matter okay
so once you've had that installed you
chose your project directory now we're
gonna be in Eclipse now to start a new
projects what we need to do so it should
look something like this by the way now
click on file new and then Java project
now here I'm just gonna name mine
tutorial and then let's see here you can
just leave all the rest of this stuff
blank if you want to change the location
go ahead alright click finish and there
we are so once we have this it's gonna
pop up in our left bar the package
Explorer I'm just gonna shrink this a
little bit and what we're gonna do is
gonna go down to source or oh I already
have a package name tutorial one second
I'm just gonna create a new one really
quickly and then walk you through this
so it's fresh tutorial one
okay finish all right we got two toriel
one and we get source okay
now inside of the source what we're
gonna do is we're gonna right-click on
this we're gonna click new and we're
going to click on package now I
recommend you just leave this package
name the same as your project so I'm
gonna do that and click finish and then
inside of your package name I'm going to
click new and class okay so once I click
class it's gonna pop up here it's gonna
allow you to select the package and the
source folder just leave those blank and
the name you can name this whatever you
want in my case I'm gonna name it main
okay type name is discouraged okay so
let's name it main with a capital M
alright just because do you have a likes
that and then we're gonna do is make
sure you check on this public static
void main you need to check mark this
because we're gonna need this function
created so that we can start all right I
inherited abstract method you can
uncheck that you are actually will check
that doesn't really matter for right now
okay so now we're in and we've got a
little bit of code going here and I'm
gonna explain what this is and then
we'll get into just coding like a really
basic thing just printing a few things
to the screen before we move into the
next tutorial where we talk about
datatypes so Java is an object
orientated program language meaning that
everything happens inside of something
called classes and everything is known
as like objects alright now you're not
gonna understand very much about of this
right now if you're beginner but for
some of you guys are more advanced you
should kind of understand what this
means
so classes are these okay and everything
in java is written in a class or an
interface or something else but in our
purpose just think everything is written
in a class right now okay now inside of
this class we have a special method is
what it's called and these methods are
what I'm highlighting right now inside
these curly brackets public static void
main okay you don't have to know what
all that would those words mean just
know this method is important and this
is what we're gonna be writing all of
our java code in for right now so if you
try to write code outside of these
little curly braces and not inside of
this method that's what we're calling it
right now okay your code is not gonna
execute properly unless you know what
you're doing which in our case we don't
yet so all the code were writing goes
inside of this public static void main
inside of these curly braces all right
now the first thing I'm gonna get us to
do is just print something to the screen
so
print something in Java we're gonna type
system dot out dot my computer's logging
one second up println and this simply
stands for print line okay now inside of
these brackets here we can print a
string or whatever we want to print so a
string in Java is anything encapsulated
by two quotation marks whenever we're
printing something we want to do it in
two quotation marks at least for right
now and in this case I'm going to say
the classic hello world with an
exclamation point okay now at the end of
every line we write in Java with
exception of lines that start or end
with curly braces we need to put a
semicolon and now you can see once I put
the semicolon that our system that out
dot println gets highlighted and we can
see that it now has syntax highlighting
and syntax pretty much means any code
that we write in the program so we have
to make sure that whenever we're done
writing a line we terminate that with a
semicolon okay so now we've officially
written our first program all it does is
print hello world to the screen but how
can we run this so first we're gonna
have two saves I'm gonna head control s
and to run this there's a little green
button up here and it says run main dot
Java so we're gonna collect that and you
can see that down here a little thing
popped up called console and we printed
to the screen hello world now that we've
officially created our first java
application very simple and that is how
we go about setting up a new class and
everything that we write for right now
again remember is going to happen inside
this method that's what we're calling it
I'm gonna explain that later public
static void main we have to put in here
now if you want to print another in line
you wanna print something else after we
can do that I'll show you how that works
so I'm gonna say system dot out dot
println and i'll say like hello world -
and if I save this and run again we get
hello world and hello world too
so you can see where we are right where
we left off with printing two lines
hello world and a little world - to the
screen and in this video I'm gonna be
going over variables and data types the
absolute fundamentals we have to
understand before we can move on to
anything more complex so let's talk
about what a variable is now a variable
just like in mathematics is something
that holds a value now in our case that
doesn't have to be just a number it
could be a string it could be a boolean
an integer like we're gonna talk about
the different values and those are what
are known as data types or objects so
let's start by just creating a variable
a to create a variable we need to first
figure out what type our variable is
going to be in this case I'm going to
start with an integer and then we're
going to go through all the different
types and talk about with the
differences so to start we're gonna type
int declaring that this variable that
we're about to type out is going to be
an integer we're then going to give a
variable name now the variable name
should contain typically just letters
and underscores now I believe you can
use numbers as long as it's at the end
but our purpose we're not going to do
that when we create a variable name you
have to make sure you do not use any
spaces and you don't use any special
characters as well so I'll go through a
few examples of valid variable names an
invalid variable names so a valid
variable name for example could be hello
that's valid because we don't have any
spaces we don't have any special
characters and there's no numbers and
okay now an invalid variable name would
be something like hello name okay this
whole thing as our variable name is
invalid because it contains a space now
if I try to put like a what do you call
it % like this or I try to put like an
asterisks that is not a valid variable
name so don't use any special characters
you can end with an underscore you could
start with an underscore if you want to
but we're not going to be getting that
in this case typically when you create a
variable if you want to make a name be
like two words the way you do it is you
type like hello and then you would do a
capital and then the next word or you
would do an underscore representing
space and then next word okay so that's
enough of a valid variable names are not
super important right now so I'm gonna
create my first variable into the world
and let's go
be equal to by just putting an equal
sign whatever integer I wanted so in
this case I'm going to say five and then
remember in Java whenever we end the
line so this is just saying my integer
HelloWorld is equal to five we need to
terminate with a semicolon so there we
go and we see we get int our variable
name is now highlighted in yellow and
there's no issues so if I how let's just
see what it says this very is never used
okay that's fun
so we've officially created a variable
the variable name hello world now points
to the integer 5 so to prove this to you
I am simply going to print out the value
of hello world like this okay so let me
say system note it's a comma isn't it
system.out.println and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna say okay so hello
underscore world that's our variable
name and that variable holds five so
when we print this we should be printing
five the way this works in the computer
right is it says okay hello world let's
see where hello world is it's up here
alright hello world is equal to 5 so we
print that okay so there we go and we
get 5 printed down here in the bottom of
the screen now I want to show you
something quickly and this is just gonna
go this is a really important
fundamental thing a lot of people don't
talk about in programming tutorials and
it's kind of like order of operations or
execution so I am going to now put my
variable underneath my system dot out
dot println ok so I'm first gonna print
hello world and then I'm gonna set hello
world is equal to 5 hopefully you guys
have realized what the issue might be
here if not I'll talk about it really
quickly and the problem is that I am
trying to print the value of hello world
before I've declared it because the in
programming the way things work is
unless you otherwise specify we're gonna
be reading from top to bottom and left
to right just the way you'd read a book
right so we first read this line system
dot out dot println hello world and then
we create hello world so here we don't
know what hello world is so if we try to
do this you can see it warns me there's
an error okay you know what there's an
arrow let's proceed anyways and you can
see that down here we get a bunch of red
text and it says we call it hello world
cannot be resolved
to a variable because we haven't yet
declared that variable so we have to
make sure whenever we're referencing or
using variables that we first have them
declared somewhere above our like the
line that we're using them in okay so
there we go we've created variable hello
world we print that to the screen now
let's create a few different variables
and talk about what these types are so
in case I didn't really specify int
stands for integer and that pretty much
stands for any number that does not have
a decimal point so as soon as I put a
decimal like this like 5.0 this actually
becomes a new data type and that data
type is called a float now float stands
for a floating decimal point which means
any number that has a floating decimal
point so I'm going to say float let's
see num2 is gonna be my variable name is
equal to and in this case I'm gonna say
5.0 what's the issue here add casts from
double to again one second we're
interested um oh yeah sorry I made a
mistake there we're just gonna type
double here as the name okay not float
don't worry about float right now we'll
talk about that later
so anyways we have double num 2 equals
5.0 now double is exactly what I was
explaining before anything that has a
floating decimal point so even though
this is still the exact same value as
this in terms of mathematics because it
has a floating decimal point in our
computer is referenced as a double okay
now there's some other data types as
well that we're gonna talk about so we
have int we have double we also have
something called boolean now boolean is
true or false and these are gonna be
really important in the next few videos
that we talked about so boolean I'm
gonna say B as my variable name is going
to be equal to and in this case I'm
going to say true and again make sure
I'm putting my semicolon now there's
only two values that a that you're a
boolean data type can have that is true
or false
now why these are important is because
based on the value of a boolean type
we're gonna be doing things later in our
program like if B was equal to true
we're gonna print something otherwise we
won't print something so that's really
important so another data type that we
have is
as char now char is any character okay
so this is a little bit different from
string that I talked about in the last
video but I'm going to talk about string
as well so I'm gonna say char C is equal
to and whenever we create a character
there's two ways that we can do it we
can do it with Unicode which you
probably don't know what that is
or we could do it with single quotation
marks so by just simply hitting the
single quotation marks we can put one
letter in the single quotation marks and
that is a character because that's what
char stands for a character so like
something on your keyboard in quotation
marks now a character could be for
example 9 in quotation marks so that's
still a valid character because it's in
quotation marks it's different than the
number like 9 if your if I were to type
that up here okay so any letter or
character that goes in quotation marks
is a char now we have to be careful
because chars can only be one one
character if I try to do like 0 3 you
can see that we're getting red text and
job is yelling at us and it's saying no
that's not allowed because we can only
have one thing all right now I just want
to show you I want to go over again
really quickly what the main differences
between this 9 and this 9 up here we've
declared we're gonna have an integer
named Tolo world and it's set equal to 9
okay that's what it is this is a
character and since it's in quotation
marks this is not the same thing as 9
the way like the datatypes really do
matter in this sense okay so I'm just
gonna change this back to like H
something for now okay char c equal to H
so that is extremely important now
string this is another data type it's a
different kind of data type which we'll
talk about in a second but to make a
string we do string I believe with a
capital we'll see and then we give a
name so for our variable in this case
I'm gonna say STR is equal to and then
at this time for a string we used double
quotation marks okay and I'm just gonna
say Tim in here so chars single
quotation marks and strings are double
quotation marks okay and strings can
contain anything in them so I could have
like six seven and three underscore star
that's a completely valid string we can
put any characters as long as they're
with inside of these quotation marks
okay same thing with the character if he
put a nine in a string this is different
than a nine like this okay so these are
our main datatypes there are a few other
ones but I'm not going to go into them
right now because they they're a bit
more complex than then we can handle
right now
so pretty much though you might notice
that this string is highlighted as a
different color than these then see
inches orange doubles Orange boolean's
orange chars orange why is string blue
you know the reason it's blue it's
because it's a different type of data
type these four data types I talked
about up top here are known as primitive
and Wow I really just did that I'm used
to typing Python primitive data types
okay and what that stands for is not
changeable okay and we're gonna talk
more about primitive data types and not
primitive data types later on but just
know that these ones that I talked about
here are known as primitive in Java and
this one is not primitive okay so
anyways let's just see now pointing out
like some of these data types like what
we get when we print them to the screen
right so if I print for example C to the
screen well you should guess what we're
gonna get we get H because that's C if
we print STR we get 9 and so on now last
thing I wanna show you with variables is
that we can actually make variables
equal to other variables and we can add
variables and we can subtract variables
and so we're gonna be doing a lot in the
next video but I want to just quickly
introduce you so for example I want to
create a new integer okay let me say new
integer and I'm gonna call it let's just
call it Tim why not now I want this
integer to be equal to 9 okay but I
don't want to type 9 out what I'm gonna
do is I'm actually gonna type hello on
your screen underscore world like this
now what we've essentially done is we've
taken the value from hello world and
we've assigned it to Tim so now if we
were to print Tim to the screen we get
the value 9 now if I want to print hello
world to the screen you can see that we
are still getting the value of 9 so now
Tim points to hello world which points a
9 right so Tim is equal to 9 and hello
world
equal to nine and we can do that and we
can add variables together we can
subtract variables we can do all kinds
of cool things and that's really the
point of variables right so we just have
to make sure when we're doing this for
example that we don't do something like
this string Tim equals hello world you
can see here now it says cannot convert
from int to string because the data type
string is obviously not the same as nine
so we can't do that until we learn about
something called typecasting which will
be in a future video
now in this video I'm gonna be adding on
to some of the stuff I did with
variables in the last video and I am
going to be talking about basic
operations like plus minus subtraction
division exponential all of that fun
stuff
so without further ado let's get started
now when I first gonna do is just talk
about another way that we can create
variables in Java so earlier you saw me
do something like this in 2x equals 6
okay this is fine this works we already
know this but there's another way that
we can actually create this variable and
to do that we can actually omit this
equals 6 so if we do this we just say
int X what happens now is we've declared
that X is a variable it exists but we
have not given it a value so we've
declared it but we have not initialized
it I'll show you what I mean by this by
just doing system.out.println and we're
simply going to print X and just see
what we get oh probably help I spelled
print correctly okay wow I really messed
up on them println ok run this and you
can see we are already warned that there
is an error so we'll proceed but and it
says the local variable X may not have
been initialized so before we can
actually use the variable X when we set
up like this we have to initialize it
now to do that any line underneath this
declaration we can just say X is equal
to and then whatever value you want it
to be as long as it's an integer value
so in this case I'm going to say X
equals 6 and now if we run the program
everything works fine and we get 6 now
obviously we can do this with every
datatype so if I do like char and char X
right and that's fine I say char x
equals single quotation marks F like
that okay then we can print that out and
that will work fine now what I want to
talk about now is operations so I am
going to create a few variables I'm
going to say integer X equals 5
don't forget your semicolon integer y
equals 7 and I'll say int Z is equal to
56 okay and I'll create one more
variable and swear we're gonna start
talking so what I want to do now is I
want to sum all of these variables so 56
7 and 5
I don't want to write like fifty six
plus seven plus five okay
because yeah that's the value of these
variables this works fine but what if I
were to change this variable Y well that
means I have to go down here and I have
to change this as well to whatever I
change Y to what if I want to change x
and y well that means I have to change
both of these so there's a really cool
thing that we can do and we can just use
the variable names and just add them up
so we can say X plus y plus Z like this
okay and now our variable sum stores the
value of the sum of these three
variables and to prove it to you I will
print it to the screen and you can see
that we get 68 as our sum now
furthermore if we wanted to take the
difference of all these and subtract
them all we have to do is simply replace
this with a minus sign and we get
negative 58 okay now to multiply things
this is another operator we can do
multiplication like this and replace
this one with multiplication will
multiply all these out together you can
see we get 1960 as our value to divide
we can use the forward slash now I'm not
gonna do that right now because that is
kind of a different topic like there's a
weird thing with division I have to talk
about but that's how you do that so
there are four basic operators now these
work just like they work in math in
terms of order of operations right so
we're gonna start off with exponents and
then go bracket our brackets exponents
division multiplication and so on
through the process okay I assume you
guys know order of operations sometimes
I do something like x times y minus said
what's first gonna operate is X
multiplied by Y and then we are going to
subtract said from whatever this value
is now again if I switch this on you're
like why multiplied by said what's gonna
happen first is Y multiplied by Z and
then the subtraction is going to happen
now for example if we have the operators
that have the same presidents or the
same I don't know like order of
operation level I don't know what to
call it
it's just gonna order it operate from
left to right so it's gonna do X
multiplied by Y multiplied by Z so this
is a common occurrence allowed people to
understand this if we do a Division sign
we're first going to multiply x times y
and then we're gonna divide by Z
afterwards okay so that's how that works
now when we're whenever we're doing
operations like this we can also add
brackets in so if I wanted to for
example say X multiplied by Y and then
divided by Z I could do something like
this
by throwing brackets in here so now it's
showing a hundred percent that's we're
going to multiply this before we divide
and same thing if I did this
now whatever's in the brackets is gonna
happen first and then I can divide by
said and obviously we can embed more
brackets in here so I can say like x y
times y okay like get out as many
brackets and layers as you want and
that's totally acceptable and that
totally works okay so now we are going
to talk about division more specifically
and then go into a few more operators
because division works a little bit
different in Java is it just in general
okay so if I want to divide 56 by seven
so I want to divide Z by Y okay and I
some just do you okay you're gonna call
this you and I print this out to the
screen 56 divided by 7 gives me a value
of eight that is because our data type
for the variable U which is holding the
value of Z and Y or does that divided by
Y is an integer so it actually isn't
able to give us a floating-point number
although we know that this number is a
floating-point number is it let's see
let's make sure this is not messed up 57
- what about this guy yeah so it can't
give us a floating-point number because
this is well and int data type so it
assumes we want an integer in return so
therefore just gonna give us the value
and terminate all the decimals okay so
say this numbers like eight point
something just gives us eight right
removes the remainder now if I want to
get decimal points which you will want
to do most the time I could try to do
something like this okay double of u
equals Z divided by Y and you mean okay
that makes sense double like it's gonna
give us the floating point but watch
what happens if I run this we could just
get a point oh well we know that fifty
seven divided by seven is
28.0 it has some decimal component to it
that I couldn't tell you right now but
why aren't we getting that well that is
because the two data types that we are
dividing are both integers which means
when we get a value back from this it's
going to be an integer value and then
all we do is convert it into a double
because we have this double here okay
just by adding that dot 0 so how can we
ensure we get a floating point well
there's two things we could do we could
first change the bottom to be a double
and we could change the top to be a
double so I could do like this it's like
double and could change this to be a
double all right and if we have both of
these double and we try this now
you can see that we get our decimal
point okay and it shows up it gives us
like whatever that is now what if I just
make one of these so I say int Y and
this is double ID let's try this now you
can see we still get our floating point
that is because if one of the values
that we're dividing here is a double
it's going to automatically make the
whole thing a double so one of them is a
double everything becomes a double and
this is the way it works for all the
operations so if you have W and in this
case we say like x times y or let's say
x times Z since Z is a double X is not
we're still gonna get a double value so
if we run this you can see that we get
this little point O so if one of our
operands is a double then that means
everything is going to be a double when
we use it or whatever
okay now exponent the way that we can do
exponent is we have to bring in module I
believe but it's like math dot POW and
then in here you put the what he called
the base and the exponent there's not a
star star like you most let me just go
let me say int of D is equal to math pow
and here I'm simply going to raise X to
the power of Y all right so we get math
pow
let's see what is this saying convert
okay so let's do this int int int
hmm cannot convert form double to form
int interesting lights telling me that
let's just try this maybe there we go
okay so whenever we get ex ex exponents
apparently they have to be in the form
double okay didn't know that but alright
so now if I want to print out D what's
going to happen is we get the exponent
for this okay so math dot POW this is
your base and this is what you're
raising the exponent to so 5 to the 7
apparently is equal to that okay so that
is pretty much it for operators I guess
obviously you can have as many operators
in one line as you want you now
understand how things work in terms of
doubles and int so if one of the
operators in the whole chain of
operators that your offers very bowls
that you're adding subtracting dividing
whatever is a double then that means
you're going to get a double value back
for 100% if all of them are integers
that means you're going to get an
integer value back now same thing here
so I have let's change Y back to double
and so let's change u to be int ok so it
says in to you x times set so now that's
x times x times y okay so now you can
see we're getting an error here cannot
convert from double to int and that is
because we're trying to say that the
integer u is equal to x times y but Y is
a double value so when we get a value
back here it's gonna be double so we
can't convert that into an integer just
by doing this and there's another way
that we can do it that I'm going to show
you in a second okay so we would have to
make sure that this stays us double and
it's nice in this IDE it tells you when
you made a mistake like that because a
lot of times you might not really see
that in your program okay now I'm
quickly gonna go over something called
typecasting we're going to talk about
this a lot more later but I'm just gonna
show you like fairly quickly how this
works I'm just gonna delete this line
and we're going to turn these back into
integers okay so if I want to do
something like X divided by Y okay and I
want to make sure that I'm getting that
value the decimal point value okay like
so a double rather than converting these
like the Declaration of our variable to
a double something we can do called
typecasting and to typecast
we are changing in line without changing
the declaration the type of the variable
the way to do this is to simply put in
brackets the type that you want to
convert your variable into and then
directly afterwards is the variable you
want to convert so in this case it's
double and then we have Y okay so if I
run this now and I print you instead of
D you can see that we get the decimal
value that we were looking for if I
remove this double right then we do not
get that or we do just cuz it says
double but you guys see the point okay
so in this video I'm just gonna be
teaching you one more operator that I
forgot to mention in the last video and
we're gonna be talking about getting
input from the user using something
called a scanner now this scanner is
going to allow us to grab like text
numbers strings all that fun stuff from
the user and then do something with that
input and that's kind of the basis of
programming right based on what a user
does we want to do something in most
cases so the first thing that we're
going to do is just teach this other
operator it is the remainder operator
it's not gonna take me very long this
case I'm just gonna say int X is equal
to 56 modulus and this is what the name
of the operator is modulus it's simply a
% pick a number in this case I'm gonna
pick five okay so what this remainder
operator does it's called modulus okay
some people like to call a remainder
operator and it's simply a % gives us
the remainder of this division so this
division is actually equal to would
equal a 56 divided by 5 should give us
11 okay 11 remainder 1 is what this
division actually is equal to so if we
print X we should get a value of 1 and
there we go and that's literally all
your remainder operator is gives you the
remainder of a division I don't think I
need to talk about it too much more I'm
sure you guys want to get into the input
so I will leave that alone for now okay
so let's get rid of this line and now
let's talk about how we can get input so
using a scanner is what we're gonna do
so we'll first thing we need to actually
do is at the top of your program you
might notice I have a new line here and
this says import java.util.scanner I
need you guys to type this out for me
Java dot util dot scanner make sure you
add your semicolon because this is what
we're gonna be using to get input and
whenever we use certain tools in Java we
need to import them at the top of our
program so that we can simply just type
like certain data types and we'll get
into this later when we talk about
classes and methods and all that stuff
ok so once we've done that we need to
set up a new scanner object so we're
gonna type scanner the name of our
scanner I'm just gonna say SC is equal
to a new scanner and inside of the
scanner we're gonna type system dot okay
in this brackets this might seem
confusing but all
is doing is it saying scanner is a table
type just like string as the data type
just like boolean is data okay it's a
different type of data type but it is in
a data type its name is SC and instead
of typing like 1 or like putting
quotation marks and typing a string
we're gonna say what's equal to a new
scanner and what this scanner is gonna
be is system in which means typing on
your keyboard and there's different
types of scanners which we'll get into
later not in this video
so once we've set up our scanner we need
to actually use the scanner so how can
we do this so what I'm going to type now
is I'm going to say let's say a string
scanned is equal to SC dot next and I
think we can just use next yeah so what
this does is we're creating a new
variable string it's called or it's a
string type called scanned and it is
gonna get the next stream of input from
this scanner object
okay so SC dot next is what allows us to
get a string from the user so I'm just
gonna print out scans after we get it
because I want to show you what happens
I'm just gonna run the program in
Illustrator and we'll talk about it so
now you can see if I go down here my
cursor shows up and I'm able to type
this cuz when type hello ok watch would
watch REMS when I hit enter it prints
hello underneath it so hello which we
typed in was the input it got scanned in
by the scanner object using SC next it
got stored in the variable scanned and
then we were able to print scanned out
to the screen ok I'm pretty
straightforward that's how it works with
strings now watch this if I type 1 1
works fine but I just need to show you
that now I'm gonna do this within 2 K so
I'm gonna say int scanned equals SC next
well what's what's happening what's
wrong well the issue right now is we are
trying to turn a string which is got
which is what this returns to us into an
integer so we can't actually do that
because what per say don't we proceed we
just run into an error we cannot convert
from string to int because what this
method gives us is
a string now if we wanted to be able to
get an integer from the user for them
typing in we have to use a another
method okay and this one is called next
it now you can see we're getting no more
red lines everything seems to be working
fine SC dot next int and if we run this
then we type like 54 that works fine
prints it out for us what would happen
so if I try to type in something like
hello so there's no errors right now
like job is not telling us there's
anything wrong if I type hello we get an
issue now that's because this was
expecting me to type in a integer and
what happens in here like this little
line of code what it actually does is it
tries to convert what I'm typing in
which automatically comes in as a string
into an integer so when it tried to do
this it tried to convert hello into an
integer and no one not you not you not
you or me knows how to convert hello
into an integer so it threw us an error
and said no that's not allowed you can't
do that so I'll show you what we can do
now if we want to get boolean's and
other types and I'll show you a way to
work around an error like this okay so
if we want to get a boolean value we can
type boolean scan equals next and when
you look at this boolean that's
literally the name to get a boolean SC
next boolean okay so let's run this now
note a boolean has to be true spelled
correctly or false with lower cases I'm
pretty sure so true that works fine but
if I try to type like hello or five or
something in there that's gonna crash
it's gonna give us an issue okay so
boolean lets you do that one if you want
to get a double you can do double equals
next and guess what this one is next
double there you go and now it's gonna
expect a number of some sort so like six
would work fine but I'm gonna do six
point three and it prints out six point
three well it's actually just test 6 ud6
yeah it just gives you six point oh so
that works fine okay I'm to getting
doubles now I want to work around the
issue of what happens like we get that
crash okay you know we don't want that
crash so how can we fix that if per se
when it's expecting a double I type in
like hello well what we should do is
always get a string so we should always
say SC done next and always turn this
into a string and that's because a
string can be
anything like anything we type in here
is fine to be a string because remember
a string is simply anything in double
quotation marks so if I type true
although yeah we know it's a boolean
it's in the quotation mark so it's
really string okay if I type one that's
a string type one point six it's a
string anything can be converted into a
string pretty much so that works fine
for us now once we have it as a string
we can then convert it into an integer
so I had to say a quick cut there but
what we're going to do now is we are
going to attempt to convert this value
into a different type so in our case I
want to convert it into an integer so a
way that we can do that is we first need
to set up a variable so I'm going to
index in this case is equal to scanned
now I need to put something or with this
scan I can't just say int x equals scan
I can't I can't just do that it's not
just gonna be able to convert that for
me it doesn't know how to do that so
what we need to do here is actually do
dot and are certainly its type here
integer dot parse int okay and then
inside of the brackets for parse int
we're going to put scanned and what this
is gonna allow us to do is well convert
into an integer and if you guys just
highlight over this if you don't know
what it does it you can actually read
through the definitions in this case
it's gonna say parse is the string
argument as a signed decimal integer the
character in the string must be all
decimal digits except the first
character may be an ASCII minus sign
okay so we can tell you it tells you
exactly what this does it tells you what
integer does integer is a class so yeah
it'll convert that for us so then if I
want to print X to the screen that would
work fine now the thing is though and
this is what we're gonna be doing the
next video is we still run into the same
issue because again like now if I type
something like Hello we still get a
crash because how do we can convert
hello into an integer well we should
really first check if the value is an
integer and I'm gonna be showing you in
the next video I believe the next one
we're the one after that how we can
actually do that using if statements and
else statements and error catching later
on so stay tuned for that but this is
the way for right now if you know you're
going to be getting into
that you can convert it in or obviously
you could just do next int and turn this
to an int like that and everything works
fine for you
so in this video we're gonna be talking
about comparison operators select
greater than less than equal to not
we're gonna be talking about chaining
conditionals together which you'll see
if you don't really understand what it
is right now throughout the video and
how we can use those boolean variables
to do certain things for us so that's
what we talked about in the first few
videos and if you guys don't really know
what the point of boolean is well this
video will show you so without further
ado let's get started so I'm just gonna
start off by typing a few numbers here
because it's just the easiest way to
compare things to start and then we'll
do some other stuff so I'm going to
create three variables that are integers
X is 6 Y is 7 and Z is 10 now I'm going
to create a boolean variable so boolean
let's call it compare and we'll just set
that blank for right now so what I want
to do is I want to compare x and y and z
using some different comparison
operators so in Java
I'm going to write them out here we have
I believe four main comparison operators
four or five so I'll type them out we
can see so the first one is greater than
and then we have less than we have equal
to
oops we have greater than or equal to
less than or equal to and not equal to
now I know I just went through those
fast but they're pretty straightforward
this is simply going to state whether
something is greater than the other
thing this is less than the other thing
or whatever way you have it right this
is is equal to so the double equal sign
is different than the single equal sign
double equal sign is when you're
comparing two values to see if they are
the same and the single equal sign like
this one here is if you're assigning a
value so make sure you remember that
because a lot of people when they
compare things they forget to add the
other equal sign they just use one and
they end up running into some issues
okay so greater than or equal to pretty
straightforward less than or equal to
same thing and not equal to as an
exclamation point and an equal sign now
I'm going to go through these and show
what all these do so I so actually I'll
leave that there and because I just
remember that I have been forgetting to
teach you this if you do two slashes in
Java this stands for a comment and a
comment is simply something that the
computer is going to ignore and SCIM
it's just there for the the programmer
so they can look at it and be like
okay this is what this line of code does
whatever the computer doesn't care so
whenever it sees a line that has starts
with two slashes this is how you do a
comment it just ignores that line and
moves on so that's simply what a comment
is and it just graze out and here to
show us that that's a comment okay so
compare so I want to compare X and y and
I want to say see if X is less than Y so
say if X is less than Y and what this
statement right here that we're typing
here is going to return a value of
either true or false so we can look at
this we say well 6 is that less than 7
yes it is so that should give us a value
of true so if we print compared to the
screen then you can see we get true like
that now if I flip this around and I say
greater then okay what do you think
we're gonna get well we get false it's
pretty straightforward to compare the
two values to see if they're the same we
can do two equal signs and in this case
we get false and now this this
comparison operator some people get
confused by but if I do not equal to
what this is gonna tell me is if the two
values so on the left side and the right
side of the comparison operator are not
the same so if they're not the same I
get true if they are the same I get
false so in this case they're not the
same so we should be getting true okay
and I guess I can show you greater than
equal to but they're pretty
straightforward in terms of how they
work at least on numbers okay
now these work fine so greater than or
equal to less than or equal to on
numbers but what if I want to compare
strings so I'm just gonna change X&Y I'm
just gonna make two strings here I'll
say oops string X will say hello and
string Y and this is equal to hi okay so
see now I'm getting this blurred out or
this red line here it's saying the
comparison operator greater than equal
to is undefined for Strings
so the only ones that I'm allowed to do
on strings at least for right now that
we're gonna talk about are two equal
signs or not equal to okay and not equal
to is simply gonna say right if the
strings are not the same and if they are
the same so in this case I say not the
same I'm gonna get true if I try to see
it say if they are the same
I get false now
I want you to show you one thing here if
I type hello and I add a capital o at
the end of hello like this do we think
that this is the same as hello with all
lower cases or not well I'll show you
it is not so capital letters do matter
in program right let's seem with
variable names like the capital variable
Y is different than the lowercase
variable Y okay so that's how we can
compare those and I want to see actually
can we use greater than no we can't use
greater than or less than on strings
either okay so what I'm gonna do now is
I want to chain multiple conditions
together so I'm going to show you the
end operator the or operator and the not
operator and these are how we can add
multiple conditions together to get one
like main condition if that makes sense
I'm gonna change these back to two
numbers might be faster just to type
them out into X equals what do I have
six into y equals let's just do like 23
why not okay so now I'm going to compare
multiple things at once so I first want
to compare if X is greater than Y but I
also want to compare if Z is greater
than X say I want to check two things
perfectly valuable in many cases you'd
want to do that the way that we can do
that in Java to compare if two things
are the same is using this and operate
an and operator is looks like this so it
sees two and signs okay and then we have
to add another condition after this in
this case I'm going to say if Z is I'll
just say Zed is less than Y okay you can
see that's fine we're not getting any
red lines and what this does is it's
gonna compare the operation on the left
side it's going to do the comparison on
the right side and then we're gonna end
up getting two values so in this case X
is greater than Y so 6 is that greater
than Y no we're gonna get false so I'll
just type it out as if this is what's
happening in the computer right and that
is that less than Y yes it is so we get
true like this okay now we have a false
and we have a true but we have this and
operator in between them what this and
operator is gonna do is it's gonna check
if both of the conditions on the left
side and the right side are true if they
are both true it returns true to us if
they're both or if one of them is false
or both of them are false then we get a
false value so in this case
since this one is false we're gonna get
a false value because both of them have
to be true for this to evaluate to true
so I'll show you if I'd do this okay and
I print this to the screen you can see
we get a false value because this is
saying if this and this are true then
the whole thing is true okay now another
operator that we have is the or operator
and the or operator is too straight up
lines like this I don't know what
they're actually called the key for that
but anyways so this is gonna do kind of
it's similar to end but in the other way
around if one of the two conditions are
true the whole thing is gonna be true
otherwise if both of them are false its
false right so the way that we can
determine this again right as we'll do
this condition we'll see what this is
equal to and we'll see what this is
equal to and if one of them are true we
get a true value so let's run and there
we go you see we get a true value now we
have a not operator now what not does is
simply going to reverse anything and
this is the way I like to think about it
whatever you have if you see the not
just reverse it so what this does is
it's gonna say if this condition is not
true then we get false or if this
condition is false sorry so not true
then we get true other way around if
this condition is true then it's false
because there's checking if it's not
true I hope that makes sense you kind of
just have to play with it to make sense
of it but in this case since we get a
true value and we have this exclamation
point which is our not operator it is
gonna give us false you can see here we
get false now if in here I were to put a
false value
so let's literally I'll just show you by
typing in the value I say not and then
false in there you can see that we get a
true value so it simply just reverses
like anything that you're looking at now
I want to show you that we can actually
combine all of these operators together
so what we can do is we can use like
ands and ORS we can have an infinitely
long chain of a condition that will
eventually evaluate to true now this is
actually some kind of like math problems
you have to do typically in University
I'm gonna have to do it next semester
where you have like a ton of different
conditions and you have to figure out if
you're gonna get true or false based on
them so I'll show you like a pretty
basic example so I'll say if
X is less than Y and Y is greater than Z
or Z plus 2 is less than 5 or what do
you call it like X plus 7 is greater
than Y ok so I just typed a bunch of
conditions right how do we determine
which ones of which of these are going
to evaluate first well that is a good
question and typically you'd never type
it like this because just looking at
this like even I'm looking at it right
now after I just typed it I'm like wow
ok how do I determine which one of these
is gonna happen first
typically you put things in brackets so
I would say something like this it's
like X&Y ok so I have this first
condition out all right you put in
brackets it's gonna evaluate this and in
this case we'll get I'm not gonna bother
doing the actual evaluation but let's
say we get true ok or so we have true or
whatever this evaluated with this is so
what this is gonna do now is it's gonna
look at Z plus 2 if that's less than 5
if that's true then we get true or and
then whatever this is and then we could
treat this as if this is in brackets
like this ok so now the way that this
would work is we do everything in
brackets here we get a value of like
true or false we do everything in
brackets here we get a value of true or
false and then we'd see if either of
them are true and return that value so
you know what let's just print it to see
what we get we get true ok I don't even
know how that worked to be honest and
yeah that's how we could do that we can
also throw knots in here too so if I
wanted to throw a knot like this then we
can do that now you're not gonna see
massive chained conditionals like this
because of the exact problem we're
running into it's difficult to determine
what they are by just reading it and
you'll see when we go into if and else
statements in the next video how we can
use these conditions to evaluate certain
things I just want to show you that you
can combine multiple things and for
example I don't only have to use
variables you can see that here I put Z
plus 2 less than 5 that's a perfectly
valid condition that works perfectly
fine you can change this is equal to 5
right you can add constants like I could
just say 2 is equal to 5 if I wanted to
but that's fine you can compare with
conscience and with strings just
remember you can do less than or equal
to or sorry not less than not if not
equal to or equal to and
you can compare floats with ins and
you'll see as we continue going through
the video it's too long to go through
all them right now
in this video we're gonna be going over
if-else and L if statements in Java so
quickly just I want to fix a really
small mistake I'm in the last video so
if you guys don't know I am like a
Python programmer typically so I'm doing
Java obviously but Python is like my
first language so I'm used to being able
to use two equal signs on pretty much
anything because that's what you can do
in Python but in the last video I showed
you using two equal signs on strings now
that's not incorrect to do that but it's
not gonna work the way you think right
now so if you want to compare if two
strings are logically the same like the
actual string values are the same what
you should actually do is say you have a
string so s in this case you have to do
dot equals okay and then inside of this
equals here you're gonna put the string
that you want to compare it to or you're
gonna put another variable which is a
string so in this case if I want to say
if like my scanner object which I've
just typed out before this video is
equal to hello this is how I would do it
with this dot equal sign not the two
equal signs you the two equal signs
isn't wrong but it's gonna give you a
different answer and we will talk about
that in future videos but it's too
advanced to go into right now so just
remember if you want to compare two
strings use dot equals my apologies
about that from the last video so what
we want to do now is rayna be do it
using if and else statements so pretty
much if something happens do this
otherwise do this and this is the basis
of programming using conditions based on
like user input or based on certain
events that happen we're gonna do
different things right so they're really
important to understand so first of all
what I'm doing here is I'm just getting
I'm just setting up a new scanner object
I'm just gonna get you input from the
user we've already talked about this and
what I want to do is I want to check
that users input and based on what they
type in I want to do something so the
basic syntax or if and else is in Java
is you simply type if you put brackets
and inside of these brackets is going to
be your condition and this is why I
spend so much time talking about
conditions in the last video the
condition here is if this condition
evaluates to true whatever's inside of
what I'm going to show you here
whatever's inside of these curly braces
is going to happen so let's start with
the condition let's say if s dot equals
not two equal signs and in this case I'm
going to say Tim so if the user types in
Tim one we're one
we prompt them for input then I want to
do something and what's gonna happen is
inside of these curly braces and this
denotes a block so this is known as like
an if statement or an if block so this
block simply goes the syntax if then we
have this these brackets inside the
brackets as a condition the condition
can be as long as it wants as long as
you want as long as you're gonna get a
true or false value back from it and
then we have these curly braces so an
open brace and a close brace and inside
of these braces anything that I type in
here is gonna happen if this condition
is true so let's just do a quick little
test here in order to do system dot out
dot println and in this case we'll just
say you typed ten okay Wow
types you types you typed it in okay and
let's run the program and see what
happens so when I run this if it loads
up that's odd okay mmm give me one
second okay so we're back I accidentally
closed my console and yeah we were
running into some issues with that so I
got that up and running now let me just
restart this quickly okay Wow okay I
don't know why that's white but anyways
let's just type out what are we gonna
say here let's type hello and see what
we get well we get nothing because we
didn't type Tim so let's run it again
let's try it this time I type Tim and it
says you typed Tim so there we go
our basic if statement is working now I
want you to put another system dot out
over here so that we can see what
happens when we have like just with this
example guy I'm just going to print I'm
literally gonna print print okay so now
what I want to show what happens here is
like what is the program gonna run so if
we type Tim we're gonna get this you
typed Tim but are we still gonna get
this printout here are we not gonna get
it well let's test this out and see okay
so in this case I typed Tim so when I
type Tim it says you typed him and then
it says print okay now the reason that
happens is because this print is not
within this if block right so we're just
gonna execute simply after this if block
happens so now same thing right if I
type like hi it's still gonna print out
print
to the screen because right it didn't go
through this if block but this is not
inside of the if block or the if
statement or whatever so that executes
okay so that's pretty straightforward
now I'm gonna show you else and else if
read start with else so else is very
straightforward it can only come after
and else if or and if so like the start
of the block has to be if and then this
else you can't just have it like a loan
it has to come after an if statement or
an else if statement which we're gonna
go into in a second okay there's
different ways to format this some
people like to put the else like this so
it has the closing brace and then the
open brace I personally like to do it
like this some people like to do it like
this it's however you want okay this
just works fine just make sure that your
curly brace doesn't look something like
that
all the way out there because that's
kind of hard to read okay so what I'm
gonna do now is I'm gonna put this print
statement and I'm going to put it in my
else statement all right now the way
this else works is if this happens
that's fine we're gonna go in here we're
gonna print this out and then we'll move
down to the end of the the block so
we'll go to here as our next execution
line now if this doesn't happen so other
words or else
then we print this so we're either
printing you type Tim or print we're
never printing both because one of them
is if and one of them is else all right
so let's test this out if I type Tim we
you type Tim okay if I type anything
else so like some random letters and I
hit enter you get print so as else works
is it's meant to do something if this
condition is not true right
okay so that's pretty straightforward I
don't think I need to talk with that
anymore
the next one I'm gonna show you is else
if now this is a way that we can add
multiple if conditions in one kind of
block okay so what I can do now is I can
do like else if and now it's the exact
same syntax as a regular if statement
except you just have this else before
and obviously since this is an else it
has to come after an initial if
statement so you can have as many of
these else ifs as you want now first
I'll just put a condition in here so say
s dot equals and in this case let's just
say hey like hello okay
and then here we'll just do system dot
out dot println and we'll just say hi
because we want to greet them back they
said hello okay so again the way this is
gonna work is we're gonna go through
we're gonna check we're gonna get our
scanner input we get s say okay what's s
is s equal to Tim if it is we're gonna
print this and then we're gonna move
down after the last L statement we're
not gonna even bother checking if it's
something else because if it's equal to
Tim then we know that we shouldn't
bother looking at the else ifs right now
if it's not equal to Tim what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go through and
we're gonna check really say okay else
if that's our next block is it equal to
hello if it's equal to hello we're gonna
print hi we're gonna move on with our
lives you're gonna move down here we're
not even gonna bother going to the else
okay now if it's not equal to hello
we're gonna go into the else statement
and we're just simply gonna print print
there's no condition it's just
automatically gonna happen if you print
anything other than holo or Tim we're
going to print print okay so let's try
this out and let's type hello and you
can see we get hi all right now if I
print type anything else in here so like
some random letters we get print okay
and that is how that works now I can
show you I can add as many else ifs as I
want so if I copy this and I simply
paste it down here I can have another
else--if and in here I could have hi and
then here I could type hello and we
could keep going and we could do as many
else ifs as we want just know that
whenever you have kind of a block that
looks like this it has to start with an
if statement and it does actually
doesn't have to end with an else
so in else just is should be the last
thing so if you have any else ifs else
will be your last thing like I couldn't
do an L if here and then try typing like
that's that's not okay you can't do that
but if I omit this else that's perfectly
fine so now I have if we type Tim we
type hello or we type hi let's run this
and let's type none of them let's let's
type a bunch of letters we get nothing
printed to the screen because we don't
have that else statement now if I type
hi you see we get hello because right we
went through it wasn't equal to Tim it
wasn't equal to hello so we printed hi
now I want to show you this this is a
bad example but it'll work if I put
lo here and I put hello here which one
are we gonna print so remember we're
only gonna print one of these things
we're not gonna print more than one so
which one is it is it high or is it
hello well let's test it out if I type
hello in here we print high now the
reason we're printing high is because
this else--if is above this one and this
is the first one that's going to be
looked at
well we type something in just the way I
kind of went through it Sakai
sequentially so since we print high here
we'll be like okay well that happens so
there's no point in checking this and we
just move on okay straightforward now
again I can do more if statements down
here you could keep typing like do a
bunch of stuff just understand you can
have as many else ifs as you want you
don't need an else--if like we could
just do an if and then else but every
time you have kind of like an if
statement or block starting it has to
start with an if it could have as many
Alice's as you want and the last thing
has to be an else if you're adding them
so you don't have to have that else
there so anyways I think that's all I'm
going to show for if statements else ifs
and else they're pretty straightforward
any condition can go here so anything
that I showed you before like you could
have a really long chain conditional of
a ton of stuff same thing here you could
have any condition like it doesn't
matter anything that gives you a true or
false value
you could also literally just type true
and like that would always happen okay
in this video we are gonna be kind of
taking a step back and just going
through everything that we've already
learned summarizing that putting that
into a program to make sure that you
guys really understand all of that and
we're also gonna be talking about nested
statements so how you can kind of add
things within other things like so if
statements within other if statements
variables and the way I'm gonna do this
is just by creating a simple program and
what its gonna do is it's gonna ask the
user to input their age and then based
on that age we're gonna do certain
things with that we're gonna tell them
like I don't know a good example is like
on a roller coaster like if you're 13 or
older you can ride otherwise you can so
we're gonna do something like that okay
so I'm gonna keep these scanners up here
that I have because we want to get the
users age but I'm first before I set up
the scanner is I'm just gonna print a
line to the screen here so I'm just
gonna say system dot out dot print
instead of println and in this case I
will just say input your age simply okay
so this way it should if I'm doing this
correctly make it so that we just get
the age right after this line okay
you'll you'll see when we do that in a
second anyways what I'm gonna do now is
I'm just gonna kind of start typing and
we'll go through how this works out so
I'm gonna say if and we're actually just
gonna convert this to int first I think
string to an int yeah so using that
parse int that I was talking about
so say int age is equal to s dot or
integer I always forgot how to do this
integer dot parse int and then in here
we need to type s so we're going to
convert whatever they type into an
integer in this case so we're going to
assume that they type in an integer so
we'll say if age is greater than or
equal to 13 then we will simply print
system dot out dot print Ln you can
write okay exclamation point now if
they're not older than 13 that must mean
that they are less than 13 or younger
than 13 so in this case we will simply
print that they cannot write system two
out the print LM and you cannot write
exclamation point okay pretty basic
program
we kind of gone through all this work so
let's test it out input your age five
you cannot ride okay let's try this now
input your age do you 43 you can ride
awesome okay so everything is working
fine for right now now what I'm gonna do
is I am going to add a else--if here and
I'm gonna change kind of the problem
that we're looking at so I'm gonna say
now I want to classify the person based
on their age is either an adult a
teenager or just like younger than a
teenager okay I don't know what do you
call those whatever younger than
teenager is okay so if you're greater
than or equal to 18 I want to print you
are an adult okay
now otherwise so if they are not greater
than 18 we want to check if they are
less than 18 so or if they're actually
well we'll do it in a in a cool way
that's gonna make sense here in a second
so else if age is not greater than or
equal to 18 we know it's less than 18 so
all we actually have to check is if they
are older than 13 right or greater or
older that or equal to 13 because that's
what a teenager would be okay
and the reason we don't have to check if
they are what do you call it younger is
or if they're her older is because we
already know that they're gonna be
younger than 18 so no we're there yet
within that range sorry what should that
explanation but that's okay
so system dot out dot println and in
this case we'll just say you are a
teenager okay like that and then in this
last case well we know they're not older
than or equal to 18 we know they're not
older than or equal to 13 that meaning
they must be less than which is you are
not a teenager or an adult okay like
that so let's test our program out make
sure everything is working so if we
input an age of 14 we get you are a
teenager awesome okay let's try it again
we input an age of 19 get you're an
adult and if we input an age of zero yet
you are not a teenager
we're an adult now I want to show you
what happens if I input like a negative
number like what if I do like negative
98 you are not a teenager or an adult
because right we have this else
statement and that's not greater than or
equal to 13 so
greater than or equal to 18 so we get
you're not a teenager or an adult okay
now that is pretty straightforward what
I'm going to show you now is how we can
ask like another question or how we can
check something else so what I'm gonna
do here is I want to say if they're 18
and only if they're 18 I want to ask
them a question now what should the
question be I want to ask them what
their favorite food is okay so I'm
simply gonna do now exactly what I've
done up here except just throw it inside
of this if statement so if this happens
we're gonna do this and this is gonna
show you nesting okay so I'm going to
say SC or we'll say string I guess we
just do in because we're going to assume
there are string I guess goes in your
food yeah we'll say string food is equal
to SC dot next line like this okay and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna print up
here again what we're looking for so
I'll just copy this save me a second and
in this case I'll say input your fav
food okay now what I want to do is I
want to check what their favorite food
is so I want to say if their favorite
food is pizza I'll say mine too
otherwise I'll say that's not my
favorite food or something like that
okay you'll say if and we have our
condition in here we'll say if food dot
equals and in this case we'll simply
type pizza all right then we will system
dot out dot println and we'll say mine
Wow
inside of the coats hopefully say mine
too and then otherwise so the else what
we'll do is we'll simply type system dot
out dot println and in this case we'll
say not mine okay so this is showing you
now it looks a bit more complicated but
we can actually put if statements and
else statements we can do things with
inside of the if statement and I'll show
you that this works so if I type I'm 19
it's gonna say input your fav food okay
my favorite food let's try pizza it says
mine too awesome that's working now if I
type something else so I type like four
it just tells me I'm not a teenager or
an adult because we don't have anything
else happening inside of this if
statement or this else over here okay
now that's really cool and that allows
us to do some neat things and you can
continually nest this is called nesting
putting a statement inside of another
statement you can continually do that as
much as you want so I just wanted to
show that to you because a lot of people
think that that's not possible they
don't understand that you're able to do
that because they haven't been shown
that right so again if I want to ask
another question I could do that inside
of here and I could just keep going
what is an array well an array is a
collection pretty much of elements that
is a set size so rather than having like
a variable equal to one you'd have an
array and it would have a bunch of
different values in there that you can
index at certain points and you'll see
when I start talking about them here if
you're a little bit confused but how do
create an array is to first you have to
declare the type that you want your
grade to be so all the values in the
array at least right now have to be the
same type so in this case I'm going to
create an integer array and to declare
that this is going to be an array you
simply do these little square brackets
you say in square brackets the name of
your array and this gives me say new ARR
standing for a is equal to and then in
this case you're gonna say new int
square brackets and inside of the square
brackets you have to define how many
elements or how long your array is gonna
be in this case I'm just gonna say five
okay so you can see that's fine not
getting any issues here just cuz we're
not using new AR but yeah this is the
syntax so whatever type you want it to
be you type the type so if I wanted to
be string I'll do string and then this
obviously I would have to be the same
string like that okay square brackets
name of your array equals new and then
the type square brackets how long you
want the array to be now there's another
way to declare this I'll show you in a
second but this is like a set length
like you can't change this length so you
have to make sure that when you're
declaring your race you know how many
elements you want to have because you
can't if you make an array length zero
then there's no point in using it you
can't add you can't add anything past
like that length okay and what it's
gonna do is it's gonna by default set
all of these elements to like no so they
have no value but they exist like
they're there they just aren't holding
anything right now okay the way you can
kind of think of it as you're
initializing like five containers that
are all gonna hold something but they're
not yet holding anything it's a good way
to visualize so it we're gonna keep the
string array for now and show you how we
can add things to array and change
values and print them out and see what
that looks like okay so the way that you
index things in an array and array is
gonna be is gonna look like these curly
braces okay so I'm just gonna type some
stuff out
just fall with me right so my string
array I want to have hello
I need double quotes hi Tim maybe I
should less values bill and Joe okay now
these are the five values in my string
array this don't type this out with me
this is just showing you an example now
the way that we start counting in
computers are actually let's first say
this every element in our array is going
to have an index okay and the index is
gonna be a number that represents its
position so in this case you'd say like
this is position 1 this is position 2
and this would be position 5 now if I
were to ask for position 0 or assert
position 1 it would give me hello but
the thing is that seems logical but in
computers we actually start counting at
0 meaning that position 1 which I'm
saying is hello is actually going to be
position 0 and that means that whatever
the length of my array is the so in this
case 5 the last position in my array is
going to be the length minus 1 so in
this case 4 so Joe would be positioned 4
and these are known as indexes it's like
index 0 is hello index 1 is hi index 2
is 10 this allows us to really easily
grab different elements without having
to know their value we just know the
position of them in the array ok so 0 1
2 3 4 that's how we count in computers
ok so how can we actually access these
different elements well I'm gonna create
a variable in just a string x equals and
in this case I want to get like value 2
in my array so first of all I haven't
actually added anything tonight right
but we'll do that in a second but how I
would do that is I would type like a new
a R and then I put square brackets and
then in here I put the position so
position so on to get hello I think that
was the first or second position I will
see anyways I would type 1 and what this
would give me is the second value in my
array because remember we start counting
at 0 so the first value would be 0 and
the last value would be 4 now maybe this
is gonna look a little easier once I
start adding things into my array so the
way that we can actually add things into
the array is what we've declared an
array and we said it has length 5 which
means that these elements are
exists or there's buckets it's not
holding anything so we have to do is you
have to say new a r0 is equal to and in
this case let's give it a value so let's
say hello okay
put our semicolon there we go we've just
set position 0 index 0 whatever - hello
okay so now if I copy this a few times I
can set the values of all the elements
in my array so I hero 1 2 & 3 and here I
can just change these so I'll say hi
I'll say Tim I will say Bill and we can
add one more but we don't have to so if
we let's let's just add one more for the
sake of it and new AR 4 is equal to we
call it Geo
oh I don't know why it's doing that for
me okay Jim like that alright so if I
say string x equals new ARR 4 then
that's gonna be equal to Joe so to print
this out to the screen now I can do
system dot out dot println and in this
case I will say X and let's see what we
get we get Joe right because we added
all of these into the array now if I
just comment this out by doing that
let's see what happens when we do a new
AR 4 let's see what we get we get no now
that's because remember what I said when
we initialize this array we set it of a
length of 5 and we say we okay these are
our containers we've got five containers
for five buckets they're gonna hold
values we don't know what the values are
yet all right so if we haven't set a
value for the 4th index to the 4th
position well we don't know what it is
so we're just gonna return no meaning
nothing is there right now okay so yeah
so those are that's how you add things
into an array now there's I'm gonna
create another array and show you a kind
of an easier way to do this if you're
just gonna like statically type in
numbers okay so I'm gonna say int the
summer gonna do an interest and me from
doing all these quotation marks I'm
gonna say and let's say num is equal to
new int square brackets or actually we
don't need that because we're gonna do
the other way we're just gonna put two
curly braces and in here we're gonna
type out our array so in this case this
is now my number array so I put it in
curly braces
and I have an array of two three
fifty four six and six now again your
streak up to would be at index zero
three you would be at index one okay
because that's where we start counting
and now if I wanted to instead of having
X equal to new error I'm gonna say nums
four which should be six right and
what's our error here change this has to
be an int my bad and x equals number
four we print this out you can see we
get the value six so that's another way
to create an array if you're just gonna
be like typing in all of the numbers
like that okay and obviously you can
create a raise of different types so
like in so we could do string we do
float we do double so you say like a
double array but nums two is equal to
and then in here you like 2.0 3.0 there
you go we now have a Wow really forgot
that okay well you need that but that
works okay we now have a double array at
index 0 we have 2.0 at index 1 we have
3.0 and yeah so arrays can get fairly
complicated they're not really the best
thing to be using for a lot of example
cases but for right now we have to
understand them in later videos I'm
going to be talking about collections
which are going to allow us to do some
cooler things rather than like indexing
elements like this there's some cool
methods that we can use on those but for
now I would just want to make sure that
we do understand a race okay
so in this video I'm going to be talking
about for loops now for loops our
fundamental aspect of every programming
language and they're very important to
understand I can almost guarantee you
that any program you write will use
multiple for loops so pretty much we're
for loop is it allows us to kind of
automate a task do something a set
amount of times and typically when you
use a for loop you're using that because
you know how many times you want to do
something or like a condition is gonna
tell you how many times to do something
as opposed to what we're going to talk
about in future videos which is a while
loop well you're not really sure how
long it's gonna go for so you do
something based on a condition but we'll
talk about that when we get to it so
let's start and just do it an example of
what if we're loop can really like solve
for us for example okay so say this is a
pretty simple example and you guys will
see in a second I create an integer C
into X equals 0 and say that I want to
add 1 and then I want to add 2 to it
then I want to add 3 to it & 4 & 5 & 6 &
like an infinite amount of times I want
to add to that variable well we could do
like X plus equals 1 we could do X plus
equals 2 like and keep going and adding
things to X and we could just keep
copying and pasting this down our
program but obviously that's terribly
inefficient in terms of a typing
standpoint and what if we wanted to
change this what if every time we were
on the program we want to ask the user
how many times they want to add like a
pattern like this to X well then we
would have to constantly keep changing
the numbers here right so this is where
for loop can kind of come in handy so
the syntax Reform I'm just gonna type it
out and then we will talk about exactly
what it does
so it has these brackets here and in
here we're gonna put three things
typically okay so what you're gonna do
is you're gonna first start off by
declaring a variable so in this case I'm
gonna say int X is equal to zero okay
now this can be called whatever you want
typically people call it I I like to use
X but you know what let's just use I and
then what you're gonna do for this next
so you gonna put a semicolon and then
the next thing you're gonna do is you're
gonna set a condition so I'm just gonna
do this and then talk about it cuz it's
hard to kind of do them step-by-step
because they all work together less then
equal to 10 and I
plus plus okay so what I've just done
here actually is I first started by
declaring a variable I it's equal to
zero and then I've said we're gonna do
this while I is less than or equal to
ten and we're gonna add one to I so
pretty much the way this works is every
time we execute what's in these little
square brackets here I is gonna have one
added to it so this is what's known as
the increment and this comes at the end
of your for loop so this is what you're
adding to the variable I which you're
declaring here every time you run the
loop now this here is your condition and
this is going to state how many times
the loop is going to run so in our case
we're going to run the loop and while I
is less than or equal to the value 10
meaning we're gonna start at the value 0
because I equals 0 we're gonna run this
loop then we're gonna come back up here
we're gonna say okay what are we doing
we're adding 1 to I then we're gonna
check this condition so I is not equal
to 1 we're gonna say well as 1 less than
or equal to 10 no it's not and then
we're gonna loop through and we're gonna
continue looping through until
eventually we get to the point where we
add 2 I it's equal to 1111 well that's
greater than 10 so we break out of this
loop and you guys will see when I start
printing stuff to the screen exactly how
this works but I hope that was a decent
explanation of the way to do this so
what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
print I here and I'm gonna tell you
right now what's gonna happen right so
we're starting I at 0 so the first loop
here we're gonna come through I is equal
to 0 we're gonna print 0 next loop we
come up we add 1 2 I check the condition
we're okay we can keep going we're at 1
and we're gonna print from 0 to 10 so
watch when I run here we get 0 all the
way up to 10 okay that's how the for
loop works so we execute whatever is in
between these little curly braces 10
times or 11 times in this case because a
0 to 10 is 11 alright now we can change
this increment we can change this
condition there's a lot of things that
we can do in this for loop so here we
say for int I equals 0 I could do for
int I equals 5 and I can start at the
value 5 and now we're gonna start we're
gonna go from 5 to 10 looping 1 2 3 4 5
6 times right we're printing 6 different
values okay so that's if you can do that
if I try to do something like
I equals 11 well watch what happens
nothing prints to the screen and that's
because 11 well that's greater than or
equal to 10 so the loop doesn't even run
one time right so let's go back and I'll
start at zero and now let's show what we
can do in terms of incrementing so to
increment here we can do I plus equals
and then any value you want so in this
case if I do five we're going to start
at zero we're gonna add five we're gonna
add five again so we get zero five and
ten and you can change this to whatever
value that you want okay same thing here
with the condition these can also be
variables I feel like I don't need to
tell you that but if I do something like
int x equals 5 then i could do i plus
equals x right and we can add that
integer to it we could add X as the
bound here so less than or equal to this
could be greater than this could be
greater than or equal to so I'm just
going to quickly go over one thing that
a lot of people get confused with for
with for loops and it's when we're gonna
stop and when we're gonna start so when
we say less than or equal to 10 this
means we're gonna start at this value
and now assuming we're adding 1 okay we
are going to stop but include 10 meaning
that I will hit the value 10 we will
print 10 to the screen now if I remove
this equal sign this is only gonna
happen while I is less than 10 which
means that if I is 10 well 10 is not
less than 10 so we are not going to
print 10 so if I run this you can see we
only get up to the value 9 now the
reason I'm talking about this is because
what we typically want to do with loops
is we want to loop through something or
look at some data and typically that
data is in the form of an array so now
in this why I talked about arrays before
I'm gonna create an array so an integer
array
it's called ARR is equal to and let's
just give it some values here it's like
1 5 7 3 4 5 okay this is gonna be our
integer array now what do I want to do
if or how am I going to do this if I
want to look through my array and look
at look at these values and maybe check
if a value is equal to 7 or value is
equal to 5 or something like that
well the way that I can do this and this
is like a dynamic way to do it is I
could count the length of the array I'd
say 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok 6 elements so I would
put I is less than 6 years
but a more useful way to do this is to
just get the length of the array and the
way that I can do that is just to do a
RR dot length or I actually don't need
this bracket sorry so we'll just do this
in this way say the user had typed in a
bunch of elements we had put them in an
array we don't know how many elements
they type in per se so we're gonna use
this length so that we can change this
loop and this loop will never crash it
will always work because we're just
simply getting the length of the array
now if I were to do equal here I hope
you guys realize this would cause us an
issue and that's because we have six
elements in the array right but it's
gonna allow us to get I to the value six
because that's the length of the array
now what happens if I try to do this
arr six well we should know from the
last video that that will actually crash
our program and that's because when we
start we start at zero and our last
element in the array is actually going
to be index five for a because we go
zero all the way to the length minus one
which is five so race six does not
actually exist
so what I'm gonna do now is I'm just
gonna write a little program inside this
for loop and I'm just gonna say if the
value is equal to five we're gonna print
it out so how do I do this
I'm gonna say if ARR at index I is equal
to the value five then your sampling
idea system dot out dot print Ln I just
realizes comma there all right semicolon
and we're simply going to print the
value so in this case we could print a
RI which we know is gonna be five or we
could just type five because we know
that is there so in this case let's just
do found a five exclamation point okay
that's what we'll print to the screen so
again the reason this is going to work
is because we're looping through
starting at zero and going to but not
but not including the length of the
array make sure you remove that equal
sign otherwise you're gonna get a crash
okay so that way we're gonna look at
every single element in this array we're
gonna check its value and then if we
find a five we're gonna print it so
let's see if this works
found five and found a five now if I
wanted to be more precise and say like
where I found this five I could say
found a five at index and we'll just put
a plus sign and we can put I
and what this is going to do is it's
actually just going to automatically
convert this into a string for us and
print it out with this index so we're
gonna put a space here just so don't get
too smushed together but it says found a
5 at index 1 found a 5 at index 5 and we
know this is true index 1 is here index
5 is here and that's a really simple way
that we can loop through a list and look
for a certain value okay
well I'm gonna be showing you a
different kind of for loop which is
known as a for each loop and this is
going to allow us to loop through the
elements of a list or a collection data
type and do something with those
elements I'm also going to be showing
you ways that we can break out of the
loop at certain points so if the
condition is not met or like we just
want to get out of the loop the way that
we can do that and I'm gonna be showing
you some common examples of where we use
loops so let's go ahead and get started
so you can see that I have two arrays
here once named names and one is named
AR I just added this names one it's just
blank blank array for right now okay so
when I first want to do is in the last
video I looped through this array and
the way I did that was by having a
variable I we waited until it was what
do you call it greater than the length
of the list and then once it was we
simply broke out of that that loop right
okay so a easier way to do this is to do
something like this so we're gonna have
the same exact syntax except in these
brackets something is gonna be different
okay what I'm gonna do if I want to loop
through every element in this list is I
can do something like this I can say for
element : ARR now what this is actually
gonna do I have to do this I'm sorry
string element R I can't say string
because that's something a type int
element in our array so what I'm doing
now is I'm saying that every time we
loop through this loop right what we're
gonna do is we're going to declare a new
variable called element and it is going
to be equal to the next element in our
array so in this case when we first loop
element is going to be equal to one and
that element is gonna equal to five and
then it's gonna be equal to seven and
then three and then four and then five
and this is a way easier way if I wanted
to like print out the element or look at
certain elements to do so rather than
having to have like a counter variable I
and then index all of the different
elements especially if we don't know the
length of the array or we don't want to
do dot length cuz this is automatically
gonna go from start to end okay now I'm
gonna show you because obviously we need
an example to really understand this but
the first example I typically like to
just printing out all these elements to
show you that is indeed working so in
this case we'll say element okay and
we'll just print this to the screen and
see what we get so in this case you see
we get one five seven three four five so
right starting at the beginning going to
the end the way this works what the
colon is again we're just grabbing the
elements in order and we're using those
as a variable element now a lot of times
what you want to do with this is you
want to be checking the element but you
also want the index as well so you want
the element and you want the index now
we could use what we used in the last
video where we just have a counter
variable in that way we have the index
and the element because we can do like
ARR of one like all that okay I but a
way that people typically do this is
with like an outside counter variable
that you increment yourself so I'll show
you how this works so what we're going
to start off by doing is just creating
very well is called in to count equals
zero and then within this loop we're
gonna increment count ourselves so now
every time that we run the loop we're
adding one to count so that count is
keeping track of the index of the
element so if I print out the element
plus we'll deuce
I guess I can't do that plus a space
plus our account you can see that this
is keeping track of the index so what's
happening here says one is at index 0 5
index 1 and it keeps track of all these
different indexes for us and that's a
really easy way to do that I just want
to show it doesn't really make sense for
this example case but I just want to
show you because there will be
situations where you want both the
element and the index and it's easier to
get the element just by doing this with
this : ok so again when you're doing a
for each this is what this is known as
because it's going through for each
elements in the array we are doing
something ok alright so the next thing
that I want to do is I want to show you
how we can populate an array using a for
loop so right here for example we have a
what he called a new string array that's
empty right like all these elements are
known and we want to populate them so
the way that we would go about doing
this and this is a common example of
what you want to do this why I'm showing
you this is we create a variable we're
gonna say again int
I equals zero we will say well I is less
than and then names dot blank right and
then we'll do semicolon and we'll simply
add one to I so this is the exact same
thing as we've done before but I'm just
gonna show you how we can actually add
the elements because it's a really
common use case
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm
actually gonna use the scanner to get a
new variable or to get like a name from
the user so I'm just gonna say scanner
SC equals new scanner and then we need
system dot in okay and I actually think
I should probably not declare this every
loop put it up here because we're just
gonna use the scanner right so we'll say
string of input equals SC dot next line
like this and this way every time we run
the loop we are going to get input from
the user and you know what let's also
just print out here system.out.println
and just tell the user we want I should
we'll just do print not Ln will say
input like this so that way they know
what to type in okay so input we're
getting input and now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to add the users input
into our array so how can I do this well
this is really easy I can just do names
I is equal to input right so we're just
declaring that whatever index we are in
the loop right now so whatever value of
I well that value in the list or sorry
the list I keep calling a list it's an
array I'm just used to python is gonna
be equal to whatever we typed in and
then if we want to print out the entire
right what we can use we'll use another
for loop so we'll just say 4 and then
this time it's gonna be a for each loop
right so we'll say 4 and it's just an
for name so you need string and in names
okay then we will simply just do it
system dot out dot println and we will
print every value of n ok so that's two
good examples let's run this and just
make sure everything's working so we run
this input on skin type hello I guess I
wanted names in it
Tim Bob Joe bill and then there we go so
we ran that five times and we get hello
Tim Bob Joe and Bill awesome there we go
so that uh gives us all the values that
we need ok ok so now what I want to show
you guys is how we can break out of the
loop so if we're in the loop and we're
going through and we're doing operations
and we've not yet met the condition
where are like so the loop is gonna keep
going like eyes not greater than
whatever value or whatnot ok then we
want to break out of it how can we do
that so how can we just get out of it in
the middle of looping well there is this
magical little keyword called break and
what this does is whenever this is
encountered inside of a loop it simply
breaks out of the loop so in this case
what would happen is since I have break
at the end we would do these first three
lines then we just break and this would
only happen one time no matter what no
matter what I mean this stuff said this
loop would only happen at once now I'm
gonna show you just down here in this
loop how we can break out based on like
a certain condition so for example say
we encountered the word end or what do
you call it - word Tim what am I saying
and I was just reading that if we
encounter like the word Tim while we
were reading through the list of names
then we just want to break out like we
don't want to print any more names
anymore we just want to break out so the
way that I can do this is I now I can
say well we're gonna we're gonna print
Tim but we'll break after Tim okay so
what I'm gonna do in a duel if statement
I'm gonna say if and equals equals or
not equal to ghost dot equals okay and
in this case we'll just simply put Tim
in here then what we are going to do is
we're going to break and in this case
now whenever we encounter Tim we are
simply breaking onto a loop and that
means we will not print the rest of the
names so if I run this just drag this
console up here and we run and you say
hello let me say name and let me say Tim
and I'll just show you this Tim and Tim
and I run this here you see we get hello
name and Tim and these other two Tim's
do not print and again that's because
once we hit Tim and
is equal to Tim we simply break okay and
we get out of the loop and that's like a
really easy way to just break out of the
loop and this is gonna work for Wallops
that we do in what do you call it the
next video now typically break is not
something you want to be using a lot
like you only use this if you really
have to it's better to just make these
conditions work the way they should and
have the loop run like as many times as
it needs to run you know what I mean so
just try not to use this too much but I
mean there's nothing really wrong with
using it people just start frown upon it
in the programming world using the word
break okay
we're gonna be talking about while loops
now while loops are very similar to for
loops anything you do with the for loop
you can indeed do with the while loop
that being said they do have different
use cases in terms of where they're most
useful but just remember anything you do
with the for loop you can do with the
while loop anything you do with the
while loop you can do with the for loop
they're completely interchangeable and
if you only had one of them in
programming you'd still be able to do
everything it just might be not as I
don't know nice to code that's the right
word for it or elegant is probably the
better word so a while loop is gonna
work when you typically don't know how
many times you want to loop through
something so it's kind of like a
question like you know it's gonna be
based on this condition but you're not
really sure like if a for loop is more
like you know you're gonna do it a set
amount of times a while loop is it could
change based on the program based on
user input okay something like that so
what we're gonna do here with this while
loop is I'm just gonna set one up and
then we'll just talk about exactly what
it does so in this case what I want my
while loop to do is I want it to just
continually keep asking the user for
input until they give me like a certain
word or like one or of two words okay so
in this case what I'm doing I'm just
gonna say let's see maybe just get
answers me faster say int x equals SC
dot next int like this okay and what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna keep looping
through until they type the number 10
okay so I can do this is you just have
to keep word while in here and then in
these brackets is gonna be your
condition now this is why I focus so
much about conditions in the first few
videos because they go a lot with if
loops while loops for loops so whenever
while this condition is true then we're
gonna run the loop so in this case I'm
gonna say Wow X does not equal 10 okay
yeah exactly that's true
so in if they type in 10 then it will
not continue to do this otherwise we
will continue to do this so that means
I'm also gonna have to get the int in
here because every time that we run this
loop we want to continue getting X so in
this case we ready have X defined we
just do X and what I'm gonna do
is if they don't type in ten I'm simply
gonna tell them like type in ten so
we'll just say dot print L and in this
case I will just say type ten dot dot
dot and you know what we're also just
gonna print out because I like to do
this we'll just do system.out.println
and this case will say type a number
these or knows what we're looking for
okay and that means we're also gonna
have to print this here and it should
just be prints not print Jen println my
apologies okay so again the way this is
gonna work is we're just gonna
continually keep looping through this
until eventually the user types in ten
in that case we will break it okay and
we will not loop do this anymore so
let's run this type a number let's type
four so as type 10 down to duct-tape a
number type five doesn't work type ten
there we go and we broke out of the loop
and it no longer asked us for that
number now these are actually really
simple um it just Wow this condition is
true do you everything that's in here
and that's all you really have to know
about while loops now again like we can
what I was saying we can do everything
that with for loops with while loops
because we can also count in while ups
as well so just like I did before I can
do something like int count equals zero
and then every time we run this loop you
get to say count plus plus and then
maybe at the end of our loop we wanted
to do like tell them how many times they
messed up okay what am I saying print
system dot out dot println and in this
case we'll just say you've tried tired
you tried and then plus count plus time
this can make sure we added a little
space here alright so now if we run this
and we'll say like one two three and ten
you tried three times until like
eventually you got it okay so that's
like a really simple way to do stuff
with while loops now you guys might
notice that this code here like this
these lines are repeated up here so I
have this index and this type of number
so how can I do this without repeating
those lines because I don't want it have
to type like what if I wanted to ask a
head ton of different questions and then
do the while loop oh I don't want to
have the same section of code appearing
multiple times so there's actually
something called a do-while loop so what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna erase all
this and I'm going to set up this a
do-while loop and it's pretty much what
it says we're gonna do everything while
this is true and you'll see how it works
in just a second so I'm gonna type the
keyword do brackets and now everything
in this brackets is what is gonna happen
while the condition that I put down here
is true so the condition here is gonna
be the same well X does not equal 10
we're gonna do everything in here so now
you can see this is working fine there's
no issues and what I'm gonna simply do
is I'm going to take this these two
lines here I don't need that scanner so
we're not gonna redefine that every time
and I'm going to paste them in here and
what this is gonna allow us to do now is
X does not equal 0 create local gosh
okay uh let's just do this int X and
then okay perfect they reel so sorry
that was just a quick issue but what
this is going to allow us to do is we're
gonna do this once no matter what this
is gonna happen once because we're gonna
do this and at this point X is not equal
to 10 so we're automatically gonna do
this once which means we don't have to
have it up top and then down below so we
do that and then we check the condition
if it's true
we'll do it again or yeah and if it's
not then you will break so we can do
this we'll say type a number let's do 4
let's do 5 let's do negative 0 Sun
number yeah okay and 10 and there we go
we break out of the loop and everything
is working fine and that is pretty much
it for while loops again if you want to
set one up to look like a for loop then
you'd literally just have to create a
variable in this case to say like index
equals 0 you can set up a while loop so
you say wow and you say X is less than
or equal to 10 and then in here you just
say X plus equals 1 or plus equals 2 or
whatever value you want to add to it and
then you can just do what you would do
in the for loop underneath your
increment or you could put the increment
typically you put it at the end so at
the end of the loop you're adding 1
check okay
now in this video I'm gonna be talking
about sets and lists now sets and lists
are from something known as the
collection interface from Java
I believe that's what it's called
someone correct me if that's wrong but I
think that's the name and they are
fairly complicated now I'm just gonna
talk about really think the basics of
them there's a lot more to do with sets
and lists I know I'm probably gonna get
some comment from some guy who says wow
you really you didn't talk about a lot
of this you but I can't explain all of
it to you guys right now because it's
very difficult to understand if you
don't know a lot about data structures
which in our case we don't so I'm just
going to talk about what a list is what
a set is quickly and a very basic
standard implementation of them now the
reason I'm doing this is because
whenever you're programming stuff like a
lot of Java throws you watch probably
won't talk about these because they're
really complicated but you're gonna need
them to do certain things so for example
with an array what I talked about before
how you could like you had to set the
size of the array like you had to know
how many elements you wanted you don't
need to do that with a set or with a
list and that's the main advantage of it
because a lot of times are gonna be
adding things into per say a list or a
set and we don't know how many things
you're gonna be adding so we can't
define like an array of that link if
that makes sense to us so what should I
should just get started we're gonna talk
about sets first and then we'll move
into lists so I'm just gonna create a
set and I'm just gonna type it out and
then kind of explain exactly what I'm
doing I'm just gonna call the set T
equal to new new hash set and integer
okay so this already probably looks
confusing and if you're typing a sigh
with me you're getting these red lines
now what we should do to get rid of
these red lines is we just have to hover
over them and click import set by like
clicking on whatever it says there if
you don't have we're not using this IDE
just literally type import Java dot util
dot set and for hash set same thing
we're gonna click on it and import it
just because this isn't like built-in to
main the Java functionality
right so we have a set now what is a set
how do we create it well set is a
collection of unordered elements that
are unique meaning that a set cannot
contain the same element twice and it
doesn't know where that element exists
so you can kind of think of a set is
just like a big bubble and you kind of
just throw things into it and it doesn't
really know where they are
it just knows that they exist there now
you also have to understand that can
only be unique things so for example
I've created this integer set and this
is the way that you do it
so you type the keyword set in these
little like greater than sign less than
sign or if you want to call it tags if
you talk in HTML type integer and I have
the name T and I'm setting that equal to
new hash sets now you don't have to
understand what a hash set is just know
that it's like the standard
implementation of a set and then same
thing the types are integer and then
these brackets here now inside of these
brackets if you had another set you had
created like say I said created a set
called like W I could put W in here and
assuming it had any elements in it this
set would get all of the elements from W
and start with that and then you could
add things into it and whatnot okay so
to add things to set I'm just gonna do
this we'll go through and see how it
works all right you simply type Dodd so
I'm gonna say T dot ad in this case I'm
gonna add five and we'll just copy this
and we'll add like a few different
numbers into our set so let's go so it's
7 and 1 5 again and then we'll add 9 ok
now what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
print this set out to show you what it
looks like now remember I said unordered
collection of unique elements
okay so let's print this out and you can
see that we get 5 7 and 9 and notice
that this ad right here actually didn't
do anything and that's because since we
already have a 5 interset when we try to
add another 5 to it since it already
exists it doesn't care and it just
doesn't add it alright now I'm gonna add
another element in this case let's add
like negative negative 0 negative 8
alright as our element and you can see
that we don't have any specific order
now see when I printed this like I had
added 5 7
and negative eight so you think that
should be the order that we get it or it
should come in some sorted order or
something like that that doesn't happen
with a hash set okay a standard hash set
and that's just because again we're just
a bubble we just know that things exist
we don't care where they exist or how
many times they exist we just care if
they exist now to see if something
exists in a set and this is typically
something you want to do like this is a
main operation checking if something
exists that's why you use a set you can
type T dot contains or like your set
name contains and then any element in
here that you want so in this case I can
do like if v is contained in the set and
it's gonna be able to tell me that
really fast now I can't really explain
to you why sets are so fast but just
know that whenever you're looking for
something in a set you can do that very
quickly like very fast like in constant
time it doesn't matter how big the set
is the set could be two million
Hellman's or it could be five elements
it'll take you the same amount of time
to look if something exists in the set
okay and same thing with adding and
removing things from the set that
happens almost instantly as opposed to
with arrays the larger the array gets
the longer it's gonna take us to look
through and find certain elements okay
just we have to understand that so let
me in there let's create a variable I'm
just gonna call a boolean X is equal to
this and what I'm going to do is I'm
simply just gonna print X now to see if
that is contained and in this case yes
it is v is contained again if I do
something like zero then obviously we
get false that's not in there to remove
something we can type T dot remove our
set name don't remove it and then
whatever the element is that we want to
remove so in this case if I want to
remove like nine from my set I would do
that then if I print my set so in this
case T we just get five seven negative
eight because we removed nine those are
kind of like the standard operations -
I'm trying to think if there's any other
ones okay so there's one more or there's
a few more but I don't know which ones
are important you can clear an entire
set by just doing dot clear so just
simply remove everything from it like
that to see if a set is empty
can do dot is empty and this will
literally just tell you if it's empty or
not to get the length of the set you can
do dot size and this will tell you how
many elements so in this case if I do
size change this to an int and just
print X here then we get a size of three
so like again if we had nothing in there
the size would be zero so is empty and
that are kind of like similar in the
sense that you can just check by the
size and yeah so that's a hash set a
hash set is like the standard set and
that's the way that it works way I
explain it to you now they also have a
tree set and we also have a linked hash
set now whenever you use these things
they're gonna pop up here I'm not really
going to talk about what these do too
much I'm just gonna kind of show you the
way a tree set works now a Theresa is
similar to a set in the sense that you
can only have the hash set sorry that
you can only have unique elements but
these are actually ordered and they're
ordered in a tree data structure you
don't have to understand what this means
just know that it's like it shows up
ordered what's what's our problem here
just want to read this error tree set
cannot be resolved to a type mmm
interesting okay Theresa well let's just
try this
that still worked okay so anyways I I
don't know why I was showing me there
but tree set is gonna actually give us
an order so if I type T like this you
can see that we actually have an order
for the set now so negative eight five
and seven now like a ray is like we
can't just index the set and we can't
just say like T zero like that doesn't
work doing that like we were able to do
with the race but when we print it out
or when we look through the set it
maintains this order in like a tree
functionality that I can't really
explain to you now linked hash sets are
this so linked hash set again we're
gonna have to import this up there it's
linked hash set and this is similar to a
basic set it's just faster on certain
operations so I'm not like I don't
really want to talk about them too much
because I feel like I'm already
confusing you guys but just understand
if
you know a bit about like operations and
speed and time complexity do you have a
link Tosh set a regular hash set and a
tree hash set or tree set or whatever I
typed okay alright so that's enough for
sets don't worry if this is a bit
confusing like we're we're not gonna be
using these too much I just want to show
you cuz I feel like you guys are gonna
need to do this for some of your
projects or whatnot if you're learning
this for a reason now we also have lists
now list these are easier to understand
don't worry but there is again two types
so to create a list what we're gonna do
there if you can type array list I'm
gonna give it a type in this case I'm
just gonna give my integer type and
notice how I'm not typing into i'm
typing integer just that's important
that we need to use integer here instead
of int okay so a rayless integer i'm
gonna call this one t again equals new
array list and it will type integer and
we'll put brackets and there we go now
we're gonna have to import this so
importer a list up there and we now
having a list and what a list allows us
to do is it's you can almost think of it
as the exact same thing as an array
except it's a bit slower and it can
change sizes so we can add things to it
we can remove things from it and if we
gets like the end of the array or the
end of the list sorry we can just add
another element into it it doesn't
matter so we can have like it
dynamically sized array these have
pretty much identical properties to the
set so to add things you can do t dot
add and you can add like in any element
you want so you have like one right okay
that works fine to remove things T dot
remove now to index things because just
like an array we can actually index
things with the list because this is
gonna care about the position it's not
going to just care that it exists like a
set what we can do is we can do T dot
get and then we can give an index right
so but even it's showing he's always
saying index right here so I do dot
index zero then that would give me one
right because one is added in there now
to like put thing to put something or to
set something on a certain index what
you do this is T dot set and you type
the index and the element so I wanted to
set index one per say
be equal to like five then that's why I
would do it index one is five okay we
print out T here just to show you what
it looks like okay sorry that's we can't
do that we have to do we have to add
something and so to set something like
this sorry you have to actually have
something added at that index I forgot I
didn't add that so I'm just gonna add
two so what I'm doing now essentially is
what this set actually does is you have
to have something already existing at
that index and this is gonna change that
index for you so this is to change an
already existing index and before I was
trying to set one when we didn't have
that in so that was my mistake but
anyways there we go so now that works
we've changed to two equal to five and
twos up session one right so that's the
way that works I've got a thing up here
I'm just gonna read through a few these
Oh set yeah okay so that's the basic
ones again we have dots sighs so T dot
sighs we can do t dot empty or is empty
and this is actually really useful when
it's called sub list and what this
allows us to do is get from certain
indexes so T dot sub list let's see add
argument yeah so we just need int so
this is gonna allow us to get within a
certain range so say I add like these a
bunch of times
okay so we have six elements now well
what I want to do is I want to get from
like index one to index 3 and I want to
print that to the screen so let's just
take this and put this here instead so
let's get rid of T go to the semicolon
and print out and see what we get so we
get here now is five and one because
although our list actually has what he
called it's like six elements in it from
here we can just get the elements from
one two three
not including 3 so if I type like 1 2 4
then you should see we get one more
element in here we get 5 1 and 2 because
that's from from index 1 to index 4 but
not including index 4 that's what we're
grabbing we're getting all those
elements in the the sub list like that
now this is a ray list we also have
linked list
this is another data structure that I
can't really explain to you just
understand that it is faster at certain
operations than an ArrayList
so for nab to understand the difference
between this you have linked lists and
ArrayList and you guys I recommend you
to play with those and figure them out
on yourself anyways we're coming up on
about 15 minutes now almost and that's
pretty much all I wanted to talk about
with sets and lists now I know this
video might have been a bit confusing
there's a lot of stuff that I wasn't
able to explain to you guys but just
understand that if you're trying to do
something and you don't know how long
you want something to be like a list or
an array you don't know how long you
want it to be it's a different amount of
elements like you don't know you would
just use an ArrayList the way that I
showed that to you before so ArrayList
like that because then you can add
things you can get things you can set
things and you don't have to worry about
like having a designated length the
reason you use a set is when you don't
care how many times something exists or
where it exists you just care if it
exists and the reason a set is better is
because it's simpler and it's a lot
faster to do operations on in terms of
like a computer efficiency standpoint
that's when you would use a set
talking about hash maps or like Java
maps the reason I say it like that is
because there's a few different
implementations of maps similar as to
how there's different implementations of
lists and like a ray list and all that
stuff so maps if you're coming from
Python like me you can think of them as
dictionaries and I'm gonna be talking
about three different types of maps so a
hash map a tree map and what was the
last one I got it written down here
linked hash map sorry just forgot about
that one so pretty much a map is known
as a key value pair in any of their
languages they're typically called
dictionaries or hash tables or hash maps
or whatnot okay so to create a map and
I'm just gonna do this and then we'll
talk about exactly what it does I'm just
gonna create a map M it's gonna equal
two new hash map like this okay and this
is your simple syntax now too you have
to import this so I'm just gonna import
java.util so just by clicking on it and
we have to import map as well so we'll
import the map there so you see it's all
coming up now for us okay so now that we
have that I want to talk about exactly
what a map is now a map like I said is a
key value pair meaning that it's similar
to like a list in an array in the sense
that you can index things but instead of
indexing them by numbers you index them
by keys now keys can be anything that
you want a key could be a string a key
could be an array actually I'm not sure
if it could be an array but it could be
a string it can be a number it can be a
char it can be a float what like pretty
much whatever you want can be the key
and that key links us to a value so the
easiest way to kind of demonstrate this
is just to do it and then to talk about
what's really happening so to put a new
value into a hash map or into a map what
you do is you have to specify a key and
a value so you type whatever the name of
your map is in this case m dot put and
then you need to put a key and a value
in this case for my key I'm gonna type
Tim and it is gonna lead to they value
five so I type Tim and then the value is
five so I put that in there and now I'll
just show you what it looks like if we
print this out to the screen because I
think it will give us a decent
patient system duh what am I saying
system.out.println sir you guys a little
tired today
and we will print em and see what we get
so in this case you can say we haz see
this curly braces says Tim is equal to 5
meaning that if we're to index Tim we
get the value 5 now how do we do that so
how do we actually get a value based on
a key the way we can do this is if you
put square brackets next to your map
actually you can't do like that this
Python we have to MDOT and then get sir
I'm still used to the Python syntax here
guys we type m dot gets ok and then we
put the key in here so in this case I'm
gonna put Tim as my key and well you
should already be predicting what we're
gonna get out to the screen in this case
we get the value 5 and that is because
the key Tim leads us to the value 5 now
to put another thing into our map we can
do this right so we do Tim we could do
like Joe and Joe doesn't have to point
to a number it could point to another
string and that string could be like I
don't know X okay and we can just do
whatever we want like we can have the
key 1 and or the key 11 and the key 11
points to 9 9 9 okay and now if I just
print em out you'll see that we don't
get any issues and that this works fine
we get Joe equals x Tim equals 5 11
equals 9 9 9 okay now this is an
extremely fast data set meaning or down
type whatever you want to call it
meaning that everything from adding to
removing to overriding to getting
happens in constant time now again like
I talked to it in my sets video you
don't really have to understand what
that means but if you do that's great
and just know that this does happen in
constant time now I'm gonna show a I
just so show the tree map and the what
was the other map it talked about linked
hash map first and then we can kind of
talk about the differences between them
so with a hash map as opposed to the
other type of maps going to show you
this one does not retain an order so all
of these maps can only contain unique
elements or unique keys meaning that if
I try to add another key so I try to add
11 I try to add this too
9:8 instead of adding another key that's
equal to 11
we're simply overriding this already
existing key that is 11 so in this case
you can see that we overwrite it and we
get 9 9 8 you cannot have two of the
same keys existing in the map but you
can have two of the same values if you'd
like to okay so sorry that kind of got
me off track but that was important to
understand so this hash map does not
guarantee the order in which we add
things in so you can see that I added
Timman that I had a Joe and then I added
11 and it's showing me Joe Tim and 11
now this is not any kind of sorted order
because how do we sort numbers and
strings and all that stuff together it's
not in the order that we added it in so
what order is it in well it is in no
order and that is why this hash map is
extremely fast because it does not keep
track of the order of elements when they
go in so just know that if you're trying
to like look through the map because you
can iterate through maps and I'm gonna
show you that in a second it doesn't
keep it in the correct order okay now
the next map that we're gonna talk about
is the tree map okay now this tree map
is what we're gonna have to import it of
course is similar to the tree list or
the tree set or whatever one I showed
you in the other video in that when we
add things in it's actually gonna keep
it in a sorted order so if I run this
I'm actually curious to see what kind of
sort we're gonna get okay so we don't
get anything so that's that's actually a
good area to run into whenever we're
using a tree map the types that we add
to the map have to be the same meaning
that the keys have to be the same data
type at least I'm pretty sure so I'm
just gonna see if I remove this if this
is gonna work for us yes so in that case
we do get in a sorted order we get Joe
and then we get Tim because obviously J
is before T and that's what it's gonna
sort strings so if I try to put like an
a value in here so it's yeah that's even
sure I make key value I'll literally
just put like a is equal to B and I
guess we can't set equal we have to say
comma ah what's our air semicolon always
forget in those I don't know okay so we
run this there we go so you see we get a
first because obviously a will its first
letter in the alphabet so that's going
to show up before Joe and before Tim so
that sorts the order for us
that means that the data types for the
keys that we pass in have to be the same
so we could use numbers we can use
strings these or whatever diets have you
want their shot to be completely the
same for that map now the other type is
a linked hash map and what this does is
it's similar to a list in that it keeps
the same order that you add things into
it so in this case if I print out M you
can see we get Tim Joe and then a and
that's because it's actually going to
maintain the order in which we added
elements so it's gonna say Tim that was
first element so that's gonna be the
first thing that we show and then Joe
that's gonna be the first thing and then
a or a second and then a this is gonna
be the third thing because that's the
order in which we added them in and
those are the only main differences
other than like the speed of which these
things run out but you have to kind of
understand right now okay and typically
whenever you do anything you're just
gonna be using a hash map you don't
really need like a linked hash map or a
trie hash map or tree map whatever it's
called for any of the stuff that we're
gonna be doing right now
so what I'm gonna do now is I'm just
gonna show you a few methods how we can
kind of clear the maps how we can like
remove elements and some useful things
you might want to do so what we can do
to get all of the key value so to get
like a certain key value we can say
actually I'll just show this one first
what we can actually do is just cool
things that are gonna be really useful
to you and dot contains value so this
isn't see this method contains values
not available for type map hmm
interesting match contains value object
yeah so we just have to put some in
there okay so m dot contains value and
then in here we're just gonna put like
any value on so in this case B so what
this is gonna do is it is actually going
to check for us if this value exists in
map and remember the values are always
these second elements here and they are
linked up or like attached to the key so
it's gonna tell us if B exists now we
can do the same thing with keys and the
keys are more useful and I'll show you
why in a second contains key and in this
case for the KIAC I put like contains
the key five right and that will give us
a true or false value similar to what
we're doing with sets and lists in the
last video
okay now the recent keys are more useful
is because if I try to do something like
and don't get and I put the key let's
say five
well the key five does not exist the
value five exists but the key five does
not exist so watch what happens when I
run the program em not get five actually
let's just see what this is printing out
to us because I'm curious if this is
gonna crash for us or not let's let's
see here I'm not getting five no yeah so
this isn't gonna actually crash for us
if we try to get a what do you call it a
key that does not exist in the map but
it's gonna return us a null value
because this key does not exist in the
map that's actually interesting I didn't
know that in Python if you try to get a
key from map or from a dictionary and it
doesn't exist you actually get an error
so that's interesting to know anyways I
guess another method I could show is
let's see here don't values so what this
is gonna do is it actually just prints
out all of the values in the map so if I
copy this and I simply print it down
here we get M values and in this case
it'll just give me X B and five which
are all these and you can see it gives
me that in no particular order it's
important to remember values let's see
if there's any other ones we can use we
can use clear so I just got a text
document beside because I always forget
all these to show you I always forget
which ones so m dot clear obviously this
is just gonna remove everything from the
what do you call up the map so we get an
empty map and I believe the last one is
is empty and this one like that's is
simply just gonna tell us if the map is
empty or if it's not a P now how much
time we have ten minutes so I actually I
am NOT going to show you an example of
using these maps but if you want to
think about this and maybe try
programming this yourself using the maps
that I just showed you be good exercise
and that is given a string or like an
array of characters count all of those
characters into a map so have a key
that's equal to let's say the letter and
then the value for that key you
is equal to the how many times that
letter occurs or how many times that
character occurs and try to do that when
yourself and if you're able to
accomplish that well then you're
definitely learning and you're
understanding the stuff that I'm
explaining
what I'm gonna be doing is showing you
some common problems that you're gonna
want to solve and how you can do that
with the information I've showed you so
far so kind of bringing everything in
now mixing it all together and using all
the things and this is a really good way
it's kind of like apply all the
knowledge that we've just learned into
solving like a few common computer
problems because a lot of the time you
guys learn how to do all this stuff but
you don't know how to kind of mix it all
together and that's what I'm trying to
do in this video so I'm also gonna be
showing you sell like useful methods and
some things that I may have forgotten to
talk about in previous videos so yeah
that's what this video is gonna be about
so in the last video I mentioned that a
good exercise to do would be if you have
like I don't know a word and you want to
count or like a sentence or a string you
want to count all the letters and store
them in like a hash map and have the
letter as the key and the value being
how many times they appear so I figured
for any of you guys that were brave
enough to attempt that on yourself I
would show you solution here quickly to
doing that and for any of us who didn't
see that make sure you pay attention
because this is really useful it's gonna
help you also to understand kind of how
maps work and how you can use them so
what I'm gonna do first of all is I'm
just gonna create a string let's call
STR is equal to and I'll say hello my
name is Tim and I hand cool all right
very creative string name anyways so
we're gonna do that just because we're
gonna count all the letters in this
string now the human way to count this
would be to go through and literally
read like each letter and be like okay
so I have an L how many times is it L up
here but imma show you how we do this
with maps and for loops like very
efficiently in computing so what I'm
gonna do is I'm create a for loop what
we're gonna do is we're gonna loop
through the string and the way that we
can do this is because if I try to do
like for char or like X cuz it's gonna
be a character right and in STR you see
we get this red line and says we can't
iterate over a string so the way that we
can do this is actually a cool method
and a useful method and it is gonna
convert this string into a character
array for us the way that we can do that
is by doing I guess a dot dot - char
array
and this is if I literally just print
this out for you if you want to see what
it looks like
system.out.println is simply just gonna
put every character so including the
spaces into a character and write for us
so let's just run this and you can see
it just is Lily just printing this
entire thing but it's actually in an
array and this is gonna allow us to loop
through it so you'll see in a second
okay so what I'm gonna do now is every
character I'm gonna see if that key
already exists in the map if it does I'm
gonna get the value because that values
gonna be how many times it exists so in
this case say I'm looking for like M it
already exists in the map I'm just gonna
add one to it and then overwrite that
key with a new value and you'll see what
I mean here in a second so I'm gonna say
if m dot contains key of X then what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say olds will say
int old equals M get and then the key is
gonna be X and then what we're gonna do
is what's the issue here M add cast and
if I need this for getting all my
brackets into old equals M gets X and X
should be hmm interesting one second
saying I have to cast this to an integer
okay let's just do this I don't think we
actually need to do this but let's just
cast it to an int all right anyways and
then we'll say m don't put and for the
key is gonna be X ago that's gonna be
the character and we're gonna say old
plus 1 now what this should do for us is
just increment the the amount so that's
gonna go up by 1 now otherwise so if
that key does not exist what we're gonna
do is we're gonna put into our map a new
key and the keys value is gonna be 1
because we just found the first
occurrence of that letter and the key is
gonna be X standing for the letter and
that should work now after we do that I
want to see the counts of all these
letters so to do that let's probably
help my spelt system correctly we're
gonna print the line and we're just
gonna print em okay so quickly I know I
did this fast and you might not really
stand exactly what's going on but we're
just looping through every letter in
this string we're gonna check the first
check is gonna see if the map contains
that letter already so has a key
if it does not what we're gonna do is
we're simply gonna add in a key and it's
gonna be equal to that letter and it's
gonna have a value of 1 because we just
found it it occurs one time we already
know that now if for some reason or if
that key does exist what we're gonna do
is we're gonna get that previous count
and then we're gonna add 1 to that
previous count and override the key so
like if the count is 4 it goes up to 5
pretty straightforward so if I run this
you can see we get space well there's 8
spaces we get a there's 3 a's see
there's 1 d there's one and it goes
through and it counts all of the
different letters for us and if we
wanted to confirm that was correct we
could go through and count them like
that and just by looking at here it does
look as though that is correct so yeah
that's a really common way to use a map
yeah it's really useful and there's a
lot of cases in which you want to do
something like that ok so the next thing
I want to show you guys is something I
forgot to do in the last video and this
is really just gonna take like 10
seconds but pretty much to remove an
element from the map you probably
already guessed but it's literally just
MDOT remove and then you just type the
key so I just felt like I had to shape
say this cuz I watched back my other
video and I realized I forgot to say it
so to remove an element you do m dot
remove and just put the key so if I want
to remove like all the spaces which
actually would it be a bad idea to
remove from our counts then if I do that
mmm interesting why it's not letting me
remove that let's try that maybe oh it's
because it's not it's because the
character am i bad sorry guys I've been
doing string a character with space is
different yes then it actually removes
the back character the space from our
program or from our map whatever okay
now the next thing I want to show
actually is sorting so sorting is
something you typically want to do on
arrays so I'm actually going to remove
all this and I'm gonna create a new
array an integer array I'm gonna say int
x equals this cases do you like three
and let's do a bunch of different values
and see if we can get this to sort for
us it's do negative 99 semicolon there
for us
and to sort this is actually really easy
all we have to do is just type arrays
dot sort and then what takes it takes
two arguments now the first argument is
obviously going to be our array so in
this case X and then the other two
arguments are actually optional and what
these do search those three are even saw
to what these arguments do is from a
certain index so if we want to sort just
let's say like this part of the list
that's highlighted we can actually do
that and the way that we would do that
is we would type 1 because we're gonna
start at 1 and then if we were going to
7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 funny enough we could
actually type 7 now I know this is index
6 but the thing is it's gonna sort up
but not including to that index so if we
type 7 it's gonna that's 7 but it's only
gonna sort up to like the actual number
7 ok and what this does and I believe is
actually just changes the list we don't
need to say like x equals arrays dot
sort we just say arrays dot sort and
then what we can do is we new system dot
out dot print Ln and we can print X and
let's see if it did end up sorting that
section of the list for us okay so we
actually man of course we can't do that
we're gonna have to set up a basic for
loop to print these out just because
when we try to print arrays I forgot we
get that little loop or we get that
message because that's the memory
address but anyways let's say for int I
and X and then we'll simply just print
out I it's got to make it complicated
for us doesn't it and instead of
printing a line we're just gonna print
and we'll just add a comma here just to
make it separated okay so let's run that
so there we go so it actually did sort
this middle section of the list for us
right so we got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
you see 8 and 0 we're not touched and
negative 99 was not touched now if you
want to sort the entire thing and you
don't want to worry about these indexes
you can just put X in this case if we do
this we're gonna get an 8 and 99 0 all
the way up to 8 and yeah so you could
sort like from 3 to 5 or 3 to 6 or what
okay and you can see it's only gonna
sort like a few of the elements in the
mistress or in the array for us so
that's a really useful way to sort
things at quite quickly actually in
quite easily using just arrays dot sort
and remember you don't have to do like x
equals arrays dot sort because what it's
actually going to do is just sort
in-place all the elements of X and swap
them around rather than creating like a
new version of X that is sorted
where you're gonna be introducing
object-oriented programming and talking
about what objects are and getting a
little bit into classes and methods so I
think the first thing to really talk
about is what is an object so an object
essentially is just an instance of a
certain data type so we know we have
data types like in strings bulls
scanners like all kinds of different
things that we can use like a ray list
hash table hash list whatever a hash map
all that stuff okay and those are all
known as data types right where classes
if you want to say that so whenever we
create an instance by doing something
like this like scanner SC equals new
scanner essentially what we're doing is
pointing this variable SC to scanner
object okay
and whenever we create any kind of
variable selectors type like int x
equals 5 we're essentially saying X is
equal to an int object of value 5 okay
and these objects are what allow us to
have different properties for different
data types so you know how we can add
integers together or how we can do like
dot parse int on on strings and we can
have like a bunch of different methods
and stuff those are all specific to the
type of object that we're using so for
example we can see here I have the
scanner object right so SC is equal to a
new scanner object that's taking system
not in as an argument okay so we can
only use this dot next method on SC
because it is a scanner type if I try to
do X dot next and I do a little
semicolon here you can see that we're
getting can't invoke next method on
primitive type int because well that
method doesn't exist for int okay and
that's like a really basic way to kind
of understand what objects are
essentially whenever we're creating a
new variable so like even just doing
like string like STR equals hello what
we're doing is we're saying well STR is
actually equal to a string object with
the value alone and because our based on
the different types of objects we have
different properties different
attributes things we can do with the
methods we can call and that's just kind
of important to understand you'll see
more how we create like objects and
whatnot that are specific
to like classes that we're gonna make in
later videos okay so it'll all start to
come together but just now kind of know
that when I'm calling things objects
essentially that's like you have a
variable of a certain type and it's
equal to something you're creating an
object of that type okay
that's all we can have to understand for
now so now let's talk about methods so
some of you may already understand what
methods are because I think I went
through a very brief like explanation of
them in previous videos but essentially
methods or anything that you call on an
object or on an instance of an object so
just to clarify what instances when
we're creating a variable like this of a
new scanner object we can say that we're
creating FC is now an object like a
scanner object or we can say SC is a new
instance of scanner of like the type of
scanner and those kind of are
interchangeable so if I say instance
instead of object they're very similar
okay so just bear with me on that so
anyways when we call this dot next
method we call it on the like variable
right so that's that's pointing to our
scanner object so our scanner object
allows us to use this method again I
showed you before if I tried to call
that on for example the variable X that
was like an integer that doesn't work
because that object doesn't have that
method associated with it so a method is
anything really that's just like a dot
and then whatever the method name is and
typically brackets for example if we had
like an array like say we have or let's
do actually a string so we're just gonna
have another string probably shouldn't
have deleted all these but that's okay
we'll say string H equals hello and I
can do something like H dot length and
this is a method that simply returns to
us the length of the string and again
this works on our object which is a
string but it's not gonna work on our SC
because well what is the length of a
scanner so if I type that you can see
that we're getting this red line here
and that's obviously not giving us
anything because this length method is
not defined for a scanner type so that's
kind of a bit about like how we call
methods and you guys have already seen a
lot of different examples of methods
that we can use on different objects and
different data types okay and same thing
when I say like data types and objects
data types are kind of like what the
object is created off of and you'll see
that more in
videos just want to clarify in case
anyone's kind of confused okay so how
can we create our own methods well
currently since we don't really know
anything about classes we're gonna be
creating methods inside of this main
class okay now this mean class is
special because it is it contains the
dis method and remember I was telling
you guys at the beginning this method
automatically runs whenever we run the
program well that's different than other
methods we're gonna have in classes we
create in future videos so it's a bit
hard to explain this method per se but
this is a method because a method is
typically anything that sits inside of a
class and the class is what's going to
define like our data types so scanner in
Java we can't see it right now there's
actually somewhere that says public
class scanner and inside of that scanner
class so if you do like brackets like
this it has a ton of different methods
attire different attributes that we can
use by calling them from within this
function okay so if we want to create
our own method within this main class
what we can do and this is just the
default way that we're gonna do it for
now I'm going to show you why we use
certain keywords and stuff in future
videos but it's a bit advanced right now
we're simply gonna type public static
okay and then whatever return type we
want which we'll talk about in a second
so it's gonna be gonna do void and then
the name of our method so in this case
I'm going to say hey like Tim okay so we
have a public static void Tim has zero
parameters again talk about that in a
second and then it's gonna do something
in here in this case I'm just gonna say
system dot out dot println and we'll
just say when you call it it just says
Tim like that okay so what I'm
essentially done here is create a static
method that we can call from anywhere
within this class okay and actually
outside of the class as well so what we
need to do to call this method from
inside this class is we can literally
just type the method names in this case
by type Tim and I put a semicolon like
that and we run the program you see that
we get is it running just one second
here sorry okay so I figured out why it
wasn't working because we had this s
you next coming in here so I'm just
gonna comment that out for right now and
we will run this one more time and you
can see that we get Tim to the screen
now I know I didn't really explain what
this is or how this worked but
essentially what I've done here is I've
created kind of like a function okay and
it's known as a method but in other
programming languages you might see this
as a function and this void keyword what
this means here is it returns nothing
okay
because in functions we can actually
return values which I'm going to show or
sorry functions methods we can return
values which I'm going to show you in
just a second so this stands for we are
going to not return anything we're just
gonna do something in here so in this
case we're just printing something to
the screen all right now we have Tim and
this is the name of our method and
that's what we call here to trigger this
to run right so if I wanted to pass some
information to Tim so say I wanted to
print whatever string I passed to Tim
well what I would do in here is I would
type string and then let's just say STR
like that and now this means that
whenever we call this Tim method we have
to actually pass it one piece of
information and that piece of
information has to be a string okay so
I'm gonna show you right here so I type
STR I've put 10 and I put Tim in here
like this okay and we run the program
now we see we're printing out Tim if I
change this like with a bunch of MS you
can see if we run this we're getting Tim
now the way that this works is this is
called a parameter so STR is a parameter
of type string and that means that
whenever we call this function we have
to type it in arguments and what
arguments are is what the parameter is
going to be when we get to the the
method so anything that goes in here in
the call statement which is what this is
known as we're we're like triggering the
method to run is known as an argument
okay so Tim is an argument when we call
this what's happening is we're passing
Tim as STR so now it's saying like STR
equals
Tim like that or whatever the string is
okay and then we're simply going to
print to the screen whatever it is that
we were passed so in this case 10 right
now we can actually do multiple
parameters as well so if I wanted to do
another parameter I wanted to pass two
pieces of information every time we call
this function I would say maybe int and
X okay and now it means that I have to
pass not only a string but I have to
pass an int so that means we have to
type an integer here in this case I'm
gonna do four what I'm gonna do now
you're going to say four and we'll say
int I and we'll say I is less than X
let's say I plus plus we're just going
to print this that many times okay so
let's see here
boom okay so system dot out dot print
line what's weird again here initialized
variable I've got to do that sorry okay
so now we pass an int and we pass a
string and what we're going to do is
simply print this as many times as like
the int that we typed in okay so you can
see that now we get ten four times to
the screen and that's how that works so
we have arguments in here the two
arguments are Tim and four and then we
have our parameters which are STR and X
and when we pass our information and STR
gets equal to Tim and X gets equal to
four okay and then in here we can now
use those values by referencing STR and
X like I've done so okay so I hope that
makes sense now in terms of this public
static I'm gonna talk about this in the
next video for right now all this means
is that you can call this not on an
instance of the class which is kind of
what we're doing here when we're just
calling Tim okay because we don't have
any object that's like a class main
which you'll see in the next video okay
so that's kind of how we can create our
own methods again we can create methods
that return things so that's what I
wanted to talk about now so all I'm
going to do is gonna create another
method and I'm gonna say this is public
static and in this case I want to return
an integer value to whoever's calling
this okay or wherever this is being
called so I'm gonna type int because
this is what I'm gonna return and the
function is gonna give back to us or the
methods gonna give back to us and I'm
gonna say add to as the name and we're
simply going to take an integer X as our
one parameter here see what the issue is
here method must return yeah okay so you
can see is already giving us a red line
saying that we have to return a value in
this method because we typed in the fact
that we're going to turn an int okay so
what I'm gonna do here is I'm simply
going to return X plus two and what this
is doing now seven
going is it's just taking a value X and
it's adding to do it and it's returning
the value to our program wherever we
call it so let's just do something up
here and show you how this is working so
I'm going to say system dot out dot
println and here I'm something I'm type
add to and then give it a number in this
case 6 now you can probably guess what
this is gonna give us but essentially
what's happening here is we're calling
add 2 we're giving it the value 6 so our
argument is 6 it's coming in here and
the parameter X is now set equal to 6
we're going to return so back to
wherever we called this X plus 2 in this
case 8 so we get 8 here as a value and
we go boom and we bring it up here and
now this little line is equal to 8 so
we're gonna print it to the screen and
you can see that we get 8 as a value
like that now obviously in methods like
this you're probably gonna do some more
advanced things than just adding to that
shows you how we can return values and
I'll do one last example of returning
maybe like a string value so public
static string okay and we'll just say
STR as their name because I don't really
know what to do and we'll take a string
X ok and then in here we have to return
a string value so what we could do is we
could return X plus and an exclamation
point but I think I need to put that in
double quotation marks like that so what
we're doing now is we're adding an
exclamation point to the end of our
string and we're returning that so if I
call STR here okay so well I don't know
why keeps doing with my brackets we'll
do STR and then inside our brackets will
give its high it should return to us
high with an exclamation point and
indeed it does and yeah that's kind of
how methods work basically
gonna be going over classes when we talk
about creating classes creating some
methods construct your methods all that
fun stuff creating instances and objects
and yeah so this is gonna be kind of an
advanced video don't if you've been
following along so far you'll definitely
be able to follow along with it but just
know that now we're kind of getting into
some harder aspects of Java so if you
guys don't understand this please don't
hesitate to join my discord server ask
me some questions leave a comment down
below because this is absolutely
fundamental and you have to understand
this before you can really start doing
any serious programming and that goes
for kind of all languages but Java
especially since it is an
object-oriented language we need to
understand classes and how to create
classes so without further ado let's get
started so so far we've been working in
this class called main now this is not
really a true class because this class
all it's doing for us is just running
some code right away when we run the
program and that's why we have this
public static void main function that
automatically triggers whenever we click
this little green run-button okay so
what I'm gonna do now and you can see
that I have some methods that I've added
in here that we just kind of use within
here earlier okay what I'm gonna do now
is I'm going to create my own class from
scripts from scratch and we're gonna
start coding so to do this we're gonna
go to whatever our package is so in this
case tutorial 1 for me and I'm gonna go
new and class and I just did that by
right clicking and now I'm gonna give my
class a name now for this example I'm
going to create a dog class and yeah you
guys can create whatever you want but I
would recommend you follow along with me
since you guys are most likely new to
classes ok so now we have this thing and
this says public class dog you can see
we open up in a new file so whenever we
create a new class in Java we have to
actually create a new file for that now
it's actually good because it makes it
really easy to navigate between
different classes
whereas in something like Python you can
just have all your classes on one file
ok so what we're gonna do now is we have
this public class dog so what does this
what does this mean like what is a class
well a class is pretty much a data type
and whenever we create an instance of a
class like an object of a certain type
all we're doing is we're just using all
the information within the class to like
create an object so it you can almost
think of it as like a blueprint for an
object now what problems do classes
solve for
like why are they useful so I'm gonna
introduce kind of a very simple problem
alright so I want to create five dogs
okay I want to have five dogs I want
each dog to have a name I want each dog
to have an age and I want to at some
point be able to like call something and
print out the each dog's name an age in
like a nice form okay now we could do
that we know how to do that if we went
back into main here what we could do in
this little what-do-you-call-it method
here is we could just type a bunch of
hints we could say int like dog 1 and
this is equal to 4 and that's dog ones
age when you say int dog 2 and that's it
go to 5 we could go on and we could
create 10 variables 5 for the age and 5
for the the names right and then we
could go and we could print out each one
each time but that is incredibly
inefficient and what if I wanted to have
like 10,000 dogs well what would I do
then well we could use like lists to
create or lists or arrays to create
names and ages that's just not efficient
it doesn't look as good in our actual
coding so what we're going to do is
going to use a class and you'll see how
we can kind of accomplish this problem
so within classes we have methods and we
have attributes
okay now attributes are kind of like
variables that hold information for us
so in this case we want to have two
attributes in our dog class and these
are going to be the name and the age to
create our attributes this is the first
thing we typically do when we create a
class is right at the top of our class
we're gonna type the keyword private and
then we're gonna give a data types and
this gets me to say string and then the
name of our attributes in this case name
okay and this all we have to do we're
just declaring that at some point in
time we're gonna have the attribute name
and it's going to be storing some
information later on in our program okay
we can also do private int and in this
case we'll do age and this is gonna
obviously represent the dog's age now if
you wanted to have some other attributes
we've it again type private and we can
keep going and type a bunch of
attributes now what is this private
keyword and why do we have public up
here and private here
well what this private keyword does is
it ensures that this name and this age
are only accessible within this class
meaning that if I tried to do something
over here and I wanted to use this age
and this name
from this class I wouldn't be allowed to
do that and the program would say no
this is a private attribute you can't
access that why do we do that well you'd
find out in larger programs but we can
also create public attributes as well
that are accessible to the other classes
okay so if I wanted my things to be
public I can put public for now whenever
we're using attributes we're gonna use
private and it's best practice to use
more private things okay and same goes
for methods which you'll see in a minute
okay so now I need to create something
called a constructor method now this you
typically only create one of these
although you can create multiple and
what this is going to do is it is gonna
run automatically whenever we call this
dog class and the way we create this
constructor and we typically need one of
these when we have a class is we're
gonna do public and we're just going to
type the name of our class once again so
that's giving us a public dog like this
okay and you can see that now we're
getting no errors everything's fine and
in here we are going to type the
parameters or the information that we
need to be passed in whenever we're
creating a dog object now in some
instances you may have nothing in here
when you create a dog object all you
need to do is just say you're creating a
dog object you don't need to give any
information and that's fine but in our
case we want to be able to create an age
and a name with our dog so what I need
to do here is I need to type string name
and int age okay just meaning that
whenever we create a dog object we need
to give it a name and we need to give it
an age now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna set these values so these
attributes equal to whatever we pass in
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually just gonna use a keyword and
it's the keyword is this it's kind of
hard if you weren't watching you'd think
I'm just like saying this is the keyword
in pointing something but this like
actually typed out and then I'm doing
this dot name is gonna be equal to name
and this start age is going to be equal
to H so what is this this this key we're
actually doing well it is referencing
the attributes of the class okay so when
we type this it is gonna be looking up
here to find all of our like private
attributes and in this case we have an
age and we have a name all right
that's how we reference things that are
a part of the specific instance we have
this name and this dot age okay and I'm
gonna explain more and more of this as
we keep going it's hard to do it in like
small steps okay so now that I have this
constructor method created we can go on
to create one more method and then we
can actually start using this class
really simply okay so what I'm gonna do
now is I'm gonna create another method
in this case I'm going to type a public
I'm not gonna return anything so I'm
gonna use void okay and the name is
going to be speak and what this is gonna
do is it is simply going to say
something or prints me up to the screens
let me say system dot out dot print LM
why did that okay
println and all we're gonna do is gonna
say I am and I want to say that the
dog's name so in this case we'll say
this dot name okay analyst a plus and I
am you know a plus will say this dot age
plus years old okay so it's simply gonna
say like I am whatever the name is and I
am however many years old not great
grammar but that's fine so now how do we
actually create a instance of this or
how do we use this dog class well from
our main class here which we should
still have open and you know we can
delete all these we don't need all that
so we'll get rid of all this stuff here
we can actually create a object and to
do that of type dog what were something
in doing type dog and we're gonna give
it a name in this case I'm going to say
Tim is equal to new dog okay and then
remember that we have to give dog some
parameters right so or arguments because
we have the name and we have the age so
what we need to do is we need to give it
a name in an H in this case moon Titan
Tim and I'm gonna type for and now you
can see no red line we're looking good
so our dog's name is Tim and it's age as
for okay so that's great let's run the
program make sure this is working
everything's fine now what I want to do
is I want to use that speak method so
how can I use that
well what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna type
Tim which is the name my dog or like the
variable for it dot speak like this okay
semicolon and let's see what happens
we get I am Tim and excuse me I am four
years old so the way that this worked
right is we created a instance of the
dog class and the instance was named Tim
and it referenced a dog object okay
so now when we created that instance we
said okay so this instance this specific
one is gonna have an age of four and a
name of Tim all right so it's stored
that information up here in our private
string and our private int and then
later on when we decided we wanted to
call this well it said okay we'll give
me the instance you're calling it on so
in this case we're calling it on Tim
we're gonna say okay so Tim what's Tim's
name its name is well it's Tim okay so
we'll save Tim what's its age its age
that's four so we'll print for to the
screen now we can obviously create
multiple dog objects so let's copy this
and let's create a few more we'll create
three dog objects and I say this is Bill
and he is seven and let's say this is
Bob and he is 11 okay let's copy this
and I'll keep naming the same thing
let's go Bob and let's go Bill and then
we can simply call the speak methods on
them
okay so we'll say Bill and we'll say Bob
all right and just to prove something
I'm gonna say Tim dot speak again and
we'll talk about why I do that just a
second okay
so let's run this let me say I am Tim
and I'm four years old I'm Bill I'm
seven and going and you can read through
them okay now notice when we call it Tim
again it still retains its age and its
name but we do this we're not actually
changing like this is not one variable
we actually now have three different
names right we have Tim we have Bill we
have Bob and they're specific to each of
these variables that are storing that
dog object okay so that means that we
can hold like unique values for each of
our different instances and we can have
like infinite amount of instances of a
class okay
all right so that is about it I think
I'm gonna talk about quickly I already
talked about private versus public let's
create some more methods in here and see
what they can do and I'll talk about a
bit more about constructors because
we're only at like 11 minutes so what
I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna create
another method and I'm going to call
this get age okay so
say public and in this case we'll say
int gets age all right and all we're
gonna do in here is simply return the
age to let's see a return statement to
wherever we're calling it from so this
case I'm going to say is I'm gonna
return this dot H now the reason I need
to do this is because say I want to get
the age of one of my dogs right like say
I created it I changed it around I don't
know what it is I want the age well we
can't simply do something like in other
languages we'd be able to do like Tim
dog age right now you see when we do
this we get these little red lines and
it says the field dog age is not visible
and that is because again it's private
so it's not letting us see it from over
here in this main function only within
this muttering method only within this
class can we actually reference this
variable right so to get the age what we
can do is we can call it Tim dot get age
like that okay and we can print that to
the screen we say like int x equals
gonna say system.out.println and oh X is
already there great so now if we run
this we can see that we get four down
here excuse me at the at the bottom of
the screen now we can actually do the
same thing with like setting the age so
say we wanted to change the age at some
point maybe Tim got a year older well
what we would do is we have to create
another method in here in this case
we're gonna make it public again we're
gonna say public and we don't need into
this time because we're just gonna
change something we're not gonna return
something to say public void and we'll
say set page okay and then we're gonna
take an age because we need to know what
we're gonna set it to and we'll just say
this dot age equals age so just like
we've done up here it's the exact same
thing except we're just gonna do it
within the method set age so now if I
want to change the age so let's say
instead of that will say set age and
we'll give it a value of ten then we
print out let's just say Tim not speak
again what's gonna happen now sorry guys
I'm a bit sick if I keep coughing all
over the place what I'm gonna do is Oh
what's her air Tim not set age ten
return type of set age two int
mmm one second here sorry public let's
try this in set H public void I know I'm
making a mistake over here oh okay
that's why I can't do I can't set equal
to a variable I have to call like Tim
not set H my bad on that guy's we do
speak we can see now it says I am Tim
and I am 10 years old and we've changed
from the age of four so that's how we
would go about changing these attributes
later on within the the class okay now I
want to do one last one I want to create
a private method and show you what this
is okay so I may create a privates Boyd
actually now let's do it okay and we're
gonna call this ad - it's not gonna make
any sense with the dog class but just
it's just for an example okay and in
here we're gonna take actually we won't
take anything but we will get a return
we're gonna return this dot age plus two
okay now this is a private method
meaning that it can only be used and
seen within this dog class so say I
wanted to use this ad - maybe I could do
this I could do ad - here okay and just
do a little semicolon and there we go I
could use add - and that that works fine
there's no issues for that okay and
that's how you use methods with inside
of the class so like speak I can easily
every time we initiate the dog call the
speak method as well and to do it within
the class you don't need to do like
something dot you just call the actual
name because it's really visible within
here right now watch what happens if I
go over here and I try to use that so ad
- so I'll say Tim dot add two like this
and you can see that again we're getting
a red line and says this is not visible
you can't use it because it's a private
method okay
so in today's video we're going to be
going over inheritance so this has to do
with classes and this is going to be how
we can inherit methods and attributes of
previously made classes into like a new
class and then override methods and all
kinds of fun stuff this is really
important this will save you a ton of
time and yeah so let's get started so
you can see here I have this sari this
dog class that we created in the last
video and pretty much the goal what I
want to do at least in this video of the
problem is I want to create a cat class
that is identical to this dog class
except in this speak method here instead
of saying I am whatever I just wanted to
say meow my name is whatever right so I
just want to change one of these methods
to do something different but other than
that I want all of this to be the same
so intuitively what we think we do is
we'll be just take all this copy it put
it into a new file called cats and then
just change this to be what we want well
we could do that and that'd be fine but
when we have classes that are like
thousands and thousands of lines long
ideally we don't want to be repeating
code and continually typing like the
same thing a bunch of times right it
also just makes it more difficult to
read so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use something called inheritance
so I'm gonna create a new class I'm
gonna go new class and in this case I'm
gonna call mine cats alright and I'll
just click finish like that and here we
have public class cat now whenever we do
this inheritance what we can actually do
to inherit all of the properties all of
the methods everything from this dog
class is up here when we define the
class we can type extends if we spell it
correctly extends and then the class dog
like this okay now what this is gonna do
is it is gonna grab everything from dog
class and apply it to cat class so this
is known as our superclass because it's
kind of above the cat class and then cat
is known as our subclass so we have you
can also call it a child class or a
derived class and this could be also
called a parent class all right and
that's because it's kind of underneath
it's getting everything from there but
then it's gonna be changing a few things
and maybe adding a few methods to it so
typically you start off like the most
abstract with a parent class and then
your child classes or your derived
classes or your subclasses because
they're all the exact same thing just
everyone likes use different words for
them are gonna have some slight
modifications to them and kind of work
based off of that superclass right
so or the parent class okay so what we
need to do when we first do this as you
can see here it already is telling us we
need to use the constructor for dog so
we're inheriting from dog but we need to
use the same constructor otherwise all
this stuff and all these attributes well
they're not going to work unless we set
up our class when we first created the
same way as we did dog so what I'm going
to do is I'm actually just gonna click
on this and you can see it automatically
generates this constructor for us now I
could have typed it out but this is a
yeah this is what it's going to do so
since in our dog class we get name and
we get age we need to make sure that we
have a constructor inside of our cat
class that gets name and gets an age and
we have to actually explicitly call our
superclass constructor which is going to
be the dog constructor using this
formation or this syntax super and then
we give it the name and we give it the H
now this doesn't stop us from being able
to type in other properties or other
attributes so for example I could do
something like int and I don't know food
or something that's like how much food
they should get this works perfectly
fine and we can go ahead and we can
create another attribute here so say
private I don't know let's just say food
okay
and this should say int food and then
eat down here we can go ahead and we can
just type this dot food equals food okay
right and that works perfectly fine and
now we're gonna have since we're
inheriting from this we're gonna have
age we're gonna have name and inside of
this cat class we're gonna have food as
well and that works just fine okay so
just to know let's go over this again
because they kind of gone through it
pretty quickly but all of these methods
here we're gonna be able to use within
our cat class because well we're
inheriting we're grabbing all of them
from the dog class so this cat class
when we first extend it and do nothing
is identical to the dog class and then
as soon as we start changing a few
things in here it's gonna become a
little bit different but still use all
this functionality so we still have the
attitude age the attribute name we're
setting them equal because we're gonna
call this constructor method right from
our
what you call it's super right here so
we call this constructor so we set up a
and we set up name and then we have
speak we have get age and we have set
age now before I move any further let me
just prove this to you so if I go to
main here and I just create a cat object
so I'll just say cat Tim equals male cat
and remember we have to give it three
parameters or three arguments this time
because that's what we typed in so for
name we're gonna obviously you Tim age
will do 18 and food let's say they get a
hundred I don't know grams of food or
something whatever you want to cut say
there okay now I can use this speak
method on Tim so you see we're getting
no errors here even though in my cat
class there's no speak method but since
there's one in dog and we inherit from
it we can use it so I'll prove again to
you run this I am Tim and I am eighteen
years old and that works perfectly fine
so now remember I said though I want
this speak method to do something else I
want to change it so how can we do that
within the Kanna class well the way to
do this is to just rewrite the method in
here because when we do that we're
simply gonna overwrite whatever's in the
dog class so the child class or the
subclass or whatever you want to call it
whenever there's something the same in
here it automatically is gonna override
or overwrite whatever is in the dog
class so if I do public void speak okay
so this is the exact same name as the
other one all right and in here I change
I do something right so I change
something so I'm just gonna say system
dot out dot println and in here what did
I want to say like meow
and my name is let us say plus this dot
name and you know it will even add like
a little food thing and I get fed let's
see here Plus this dot food okay I don't
know let's get enough for me what's the
issue here change visibility of name to
protect it uh okay one second I gotta do
something here cat this just needs to be
sorry public and public sorry this is
just because we're not actually able to
see these attributes because they're
defined in the dog class from within our
cat class so we just need to change them
to public so that we're actually gonna
be able to use them within our speak
method we can also use something called
protected
which I'm going to talk about near the
end of this video okay so right now this
use public because I don't wanna get
into protected but let's see what
happens now if I run my team don't speak
now we'd say meow my name is Tim and I
get fed 100 okay and that's because even
though in the dog class we had speak
since we wrote it again in our cat class
and cat class is the one that we're
using we're simply gonna take this one
and we're gonna override the the one in
our dog with us okay now obviously when
we're doing inheritance you've already
seen we can add our own methods we can
add more stuff when we do whatever we
want right so in here I can add more
methods I can say public Boyd I don't
know eat and in this case we'll just
have like int I don't know X like as how
much they're eating and we can say this
dot food - equals x ok and just subtract
from it however much they ate and then
we can use eat in the cat class but it's
not gonna be seen in the dog class right
so we just have to understand this does
go one way all the stuff we do in the
cat class is not gonna be visible to
stuff in dog cost because well dog does
not extend cat right so it's kind of a
hierarchy where like dogs at the top and
then cat branches off and we can have
other things extend the dog class as
well we'd have something extend the cat
class and we could just keep going and
going and going and extending and
extending and extending also known as
like inheriting right so that's kind of
it for inheritance now I want to show
something called multiple constructors
ok so there is sometimes when we're
setting up a class we want to be able to
pass it like a different piece of
information and set up the class
differently right so for example my
counter class here at gives name age and
food what if however I only wanted to
give it name and H well we can leave
both options available they don't have
to be mutually exclusive right I could
give it either these three arguments to
set it up or I could give it just two
and to do this we have to create another
constructor so I'm gonna do the exact
same thing as above I'm pretty well
identical except I'm just gonna leave
out one of the parameters here okay so
say end age and then here we'll simply
call super and name and age okay and you
can see no red lines everything looks
fine and what we're essentially doing
here is we're giving it another
way to set up the cat class another way
to construct all of our attributes and
set up the cat class so we can either
call the cat class using three
parameters or three arguments or we can
call it using two and you know what
maybe we could set one up only using one
we're only using 0 so let's do one with
one just to show you how this might work
okay so if I do string name and then int
age okay and then here I call super oh
sorry I should just get rushed I should
get rid of this because we're only gonna
use one right my bad I'm gonna give name
but what about age what am I giving
super for for our age well I don't know
how are we gonna set it up if they only
give us one argument well I would think
that if they don't give us an age then
we should just automatically assume that
their age is zero so let's do that I'm
gonna put in zero just hard code that in
here so that way this means now say for
example they only want to give us a name
then we'll just automatically give them
an age of zero they want to give us a
name and an age that's fine we can do
that but maybe what we should do in here
if they give us a name in age is we
should make sure that food is set equal
to I don't know maybe let's give it a
default value of 50 so if they don't
define how much food the cat eats we're
just going to assume that they eat 50
okay and this is kind of a weight you
can do like it's known as like default
parameters if they don't type something
in just automatically set a value for
that so that everything still works fine
I hope that makes sense so let's show
now the three different ways that we can
create a cat say cat Bob equals new cats
and in this case we'll give it a name so
we'll say Bob and we'll give it an age
of seven and no red lines this works
fine again this defines a cat right
because that's another constructor that
we had so let's do this one more time
and in this case let's just only type in
a name we're gonna name this one vo I
like the name Joe alright and there we
are so now we could all viously do like
Bob does speak and we could do Joe does
speak and these are the three ways that
we have that we can define a cat okay so
meow my name is Joe I get fed 0 Bob I
get fed 50 right it can go on like that
so again when we have one now we just
seen a quick error that maybe we want to
fix
we should probably give them food as
well so we say this stuff food equals 50
okay as like our default value for how
much they get fed so that is a way that
you can do multiple constructors and now
I'm going to talk about protected values
so protected values are something that
we can use similar to private and public
but they're they just act a bit
differently so pretty much if you use
the protected keyword instead of public
when you're defining things so for
example here in my dog class I'm gonna
go up and change public to protected
this means that only things that are
within the same package or are
subclasses of the class can have access
to this pretty much like name okay so
that means any of these files or any of
these classes within this package are
able to see this but if I had another
package which you typically do if you
have large Java programs anything in
there would not be able to see this okay
so it whenever we're using what do you
call it whenever we're creating like a
main class or a parent class pro tected
Wow okay we're gonna want to use the
protected keyword at least for woody
code sorry our attributes so that we can
change them and access them from within
the subclass all right
now for these methods it's fine they're
public anyways right so we can make
these protected as well if we didn't
want another package to be able to
access them now if we create private
methods right if we create a private
method here I'm actually gonna try this
I don't remember if this is gonna allow
us to use this now out here so let's say
like Tim dot I don't know which one I
changed get aged okay say Tim dot get
aged so int x equals C this is gonna
work yeah so again this is not going to
allow us to use this because well we
made it private right if we made that
protect it it would allow us to use it
here but not outside of the package now
I want to try this though and see if I
can get this use this get aged from
within our cat clasp so if I do for
example I want to speak I'll say this
get age and yeah so this isn't working
as well which means that again if we
want to use those methods we have to
make sure they're either
like or protected rather than private
okay
the only time you're really going to
create private methods is if within the
class is the only area you're using the
method so for example maybe you're doing
a kemal calculation and you only do that
from within the class and you don't want
anyone outside of the class to be able
to do that then you create a private
method to do that because you could do
that from within the class right
so in today's video we're going to be
going over kind of class variables and
the keywords static so you may have seen
that we've used static and a few things
in like our main thing you're actually
going to delete all this
it says static right here and no one's
really explained I guess I haven't
really explained what static means and
that's what I'm going to be doing in
this video
so let's get started and talk about
class variables so right now we have
something called attributes guys we have
these two attributes which are specific
to each instance of our dog so when we
created multiple dog objects each dog
had their own name and their own age and
other dogs were not affected when we
change one of the dogs name or one of
the dog's age unless that dog was that
mob viously right and that's great
because we can have a ton of different
values that are specific to different
objects or different instances of this
dog class now sometimes we want to have
variables that will change or are the
same for each instance so we can change
them in one instance and if we do change
it on one instance they will change in
the other now those are known as class
variables not instance variables because
instance variables are like kind of
attributes okay the way that we can
create these class variables is we can
do something like this yes it's not say
protect it again say protected and by
the way I'm just in my dog class I
deleted a bunch of stuff out of it just
to make it a bit easier to work in and I
still have the cat class but it's just
I'm not using it for this video okay so
we'll say protected static int count
equals 0 now I know that that is a
mouthful but what we're doing here
essentially is we're creating a class
variable which is an int named count
equals 0 which is protected okay I know
it's a lot of keywords but what is this
static keyword do so what this is
actually gonna do is it's gonna allow us
to statically change count which means
it's not going to change for each
instance it's only gonna change or sorry
it'll change like altogether right so
what I was explaining before and that's
what this static keyword is going to
allow us to do so we don't actually care
about what instance this variable is a
part of we just care that it's a part of
the dog class all right so if I want to
change this value X well I do need still
need to call this
and I can say this dog count equals and
then actually I'm gonna say plus equals
one okay because what I want to do with
this count here let's say static-filled
dogs should be accessed in a static way
okay let's just do this one second okay
what I'm doing here sorry one second
I'll explain this is I'm just gonna add
1 to this count because I want to keep
track of how many dogs we have so that
if I wanted to I don't know like see how
many dogs have been created I could just
simply call like dog count and then
figure that out alright so what I'm
doing here instead of calling this duck
count which does actually work is I'm
calling dog count because since this is
a static variable or static yeah I'm
static variable class variable whatever
you want to call it it doesn't actually
care about what instance I'm changing it
on because it's gonna change for all the
instances so I can actually use the name
of the class to change it and that's why
I gave me that little yellow line and
not sure if you guys read that it said
we should do this in a static way
because well it's a static variable so I
could however call like this dot count
all right and that would work fine
because this what is an instance of the
dog class so it knows where to look for
the variable count but it's much better
to do dog dot count like plus equals one
okay now I'm going to prove this to you
that this does indeed actually work I'm
not just making things up so let's
create some dog objects here I'd say a
10 or dog 10 equals new Wow
typing is not great today new dog and
we'll just say tune and so 9 for age and
we'll just copy this and what should we
do
let's do bill maybe say bill and that is
new dog named bill age 10 okay now since
this static variable here is protected I
can actually access it from main so what
I'm gonna do to change counting are to
print count out first of all is I'll
prove to you that system system dot out
dot println
I keep thinking we're in Python here and
I'll just simply print out dog dot count
like this okay and just see what we get
is a value first of all okay so we get
two so we already know that this is
indeed
working because well when we added one
to count if it was this different for
each one then it would just be one but
anyways and if I want to change dog
count what I can do is in say dog dot
count let's say equal is like seven okay
and that's fine that works I print out
dog count we get seven now I'll show you
- if I do like Tim Couch this will give
us the same answer so you can see we get
seven even though in Tim we didn't do
anything with Tim to change count since
it's a dog part of the dog class it has
this count variable and it's changing
obviously within Tim as well okay so
that's kind of how the class variables
work now with time to talk about static
methods okay this was a static variable
or class variable I like to call it
class variable just cuz that's what I'm
used to but you can call it whatever you
want now we're gonna talk about static
methods and what that is so it's very
similar to this kind of the way that
this works but is a little different so
let me do here I mean it's a public
static void display okay and in here all
I'm going to do is somebody system dot
out dot println and I'll just print I am
a dog okay so what this is doing now is
I'm saying static void display now in
here what's gonna happen essentially is
we don't need an instance to call this
so I can actually just call this on the
the dog class so I can say like dog dot
display like this and since it's a
static method this works fine and this
will indeed say I am a dog now as
opposed to if this was a regular method
so let's just make a regular method to
kind of do a comparison here so let's
say public void and we'll say display -
okay and we'll literally - take this and
put it word for word in here just to
show you the difference so now watch
what happens if I try to do dog display
- you can see that we're getting a red
line and saying that we need to make
this static because we need an instance
to call display - meaning that we need
to have first create a dog object and
then we can use that dog object to call
display - or we can
do like this dot display too and that
works fine because that's calling it on
the instance right because this
represents the instance that we're using
so the static is going to allow us to
call it just simply using dog but the
thing with static is it has no way to
access our what he called our values or
our attributes right so if I wanted to
access like a dog's name or a dog's age
well I can't do that from a static
method like I can't type like this dog
age that just simply doesn't work
because if you think about it well what
what what instance are we calling it on
there's no instance we're just simply
calling it on the dog class so we have
no idea what age to look for or what
name to look for so the only time we use
static methods is when we don't care
about the instance and we just want to
do something and we want to store it
within that class you can almost think
of it as a function if you if you know
other programming languages but that is
ideally house static works so whenever
you want to build a call something and
you don't care about the like the
instance you don't care what the
attributes you can make it static and
that way you can call it without having
an instance so yeah so hopefully that
makes sense to you guys
I'll quickly go over what this void does
one more time in case anyone forgets
remember in our functions we can return
values when you put void all this does
is say we're not returning anything
we're just gonna do something right so
we could be like manipulating an array
or in this case printing something up to
the screen okay or maybe getting like
input from the user but we're just not
returning any value back to the call
statement
so in today's video we're gonna be going
over how we can compare objects and how
we can get a string representation of
different objects and you'll see what I
mean in just a minute but these are
really useful and I guarantee you guys
will be using this a lot especially if
you have objects like maybe like point
objects or like some kind of
mathematical objects that you'd want to
compare without having to I don't know
make things too complicated for yourself
let's just say that alright
so what I'm gonna do here or what I've
already done I guess is I have this
student class setup and this is just
what we're gonna work with right now
because the other classes I had in
previous videos were already like finish
and they had other stuff in it so we
each have a student and currently the
only attribute the student has is a name
okay now in my main Java here I've just
created a few different students and
then I'm just gonna be printing
something out to the screen so that's
why I have that right now so we can see
student class right we just created a
name for a student now I just want to
show you quickly how we would go about
like comparing objects intuitively right
so say I want to check if Joe and bill
were the same right like if want to see
if they were equal to each other
well we know how to do that already so
what I would do is until I go is equal
to bill now intuitively you probably
said well know their names are not the
same so they're not gonna be equal to
each other and well that would be
correct but not for the reason that you
think and all demonstrate that to you so
we have Joe and Bill compared to each
other so watch what happens if I try to
I make these the same name right so you
think well these would be the same
object or they'd be the same thing right
because they have the same name but
watch what happens when I run we still
get false now why is that exactly
well pretty much when we use this double
equal sign on two objects right so like
Joe and Bill the computer doesn't know
how to compare them so by default what
it does is it compares the actual object
and you see here how we're creating a
new student so a new object and here are
creating another new student another new
object these are actually two different
objects like in memory okay so in your
computer's RAM these are two different
entities and they're completely unique
although yes they have the same name
since we can change names and we can do
things these need to be
just separate objects so when we compare
here it's actually saying well we're
gonna look and see if these are the
exact same object and well they are not
now that's useful in some cases because
sometimes we want to see if it's like
the exact same object but in other cases
we want to see if these objects have
like the similar values right so in this
case we'd probably want to compare the
two names of the students to see if they
were the same and in that case we would
say well yes these are the same student
we're gonna say yes there they are the
same right when we do that like double
equal sign so what I'm gonna do now is
I'll delete this let me show you how we
can go about doing that so inside of our
student class I'm gonna add a method
okay we call this public boolean not
boolean boolean and we're gonna say
equals and then here we're gonna take a
student object known as other okay and
then we'll go like that and there we are
so what I'm gonna do in here is when we
want to compare our student okay we're
going to pass another student and we're
gonna compare their names right so we're
going to call this dot equals on one of
our students that already exists we're
gonna give it another student and then
we're gonna see if they're the same so
how did we say we were gonna check the
same well we're gonna look at their
names okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to say if and then we'll say this
dot name and I guess I need a brackets
here as well
I always forget about those if this dot
name equals equals okay and then we'll
say other dot name then what we'll do is
we'll simply return true okay now
otherwise so if these names are not the
same what we will do is we will return
false like that okay and that's all we
need to do for our dot equals so now
what's gonna happen right is we'll pass
on one student will call this will check
name and then we'll check the other
student's name see if it's true if it is
or if they're the same
we'll return true otherwise you'll
return false so now we can try this out
so these two are the same names so let's
say SGO dot equals and then here I guess
we will put bill so let's run this and
you can see we get a value of true and
if I change bill back to say bill then
we can run this and we can see we get
false so now we officially have
something checking for equality between
the names now we could create more kind
of ones like this like equals grade like
whatever if you want to do that but this
is how we can check for equality between
objects and this method is like really
easy to add in obviously if you had a
student with a bunch more values to
maybe have like grade maybe you had
other stuff like that or they go last
name you could check to make that share
those will all the same or you can just
kind of custom Li do it the way that you
want to say two different objects are
the same right okay so the next thing I
want to be able to do is compare things
using like greater than sign or less
than sign right so I want to see if like
Jo is greater than bill or Bill is
greater than Tim and we should
intuitively like do that based on
alphabetical order right so I can't
really show you like a way to do it here
cuz I don't think it's don't worry about
it show greater than bill yeah see that
just is undefined there's no way to do
that so what we're gonna do is we're
going to use a method called compare to
okay and what we have to do to compare
to is we have to woody call it sir we
have to implement something into our
class so really say implements at the
top of our class - well implements
correctly and we're gonna type
comparable and then in here relative
student now what we're actually doing
here when we bring this in is we're
actually implementing something called
an interface now an interface I'm going
to talk about in I think like two videos
from now but pretty much it's just like
a set of methods that we have to use for
the class work so when we implement this
comparable thing that means we're
allowed to bring in a method this is
gonna allow us to to compare two objects
okay so what we'll do now is we will say
public and actually what is the thing
for this the return type public int and
compare to and then in brackets here
again we're going to take student and
this will be other and we'll put our
brackets here like this okay so now
again we're gonna have to
earn some kind of integer and I'll show
you how that works I just got to get it
up on my other screen so I don't mess
this up okay so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm gonna return this dot name dot
compare to and in this case we're gonna
compare it to another string so the
other string will be other dot name okay
so essentially what this is gonna do is
it is going to compare this name to this
other name and it's gonna give us an
integer value saying kind of how far
away they are right so it's it's kind of
hard to like explain so I'm just
actually gonna do it from over here and
you'll see what I mean so if I go Joe
doc compare two and then again let's do
Bill let's see what we get so we get the
value of eight now what this means is
Joe is greater than bill by a distance
of eight meaning that when we compare
these first two letters they are eight
away I believe okay so if we wanted to
check if Joe was greater than bill what
we do is we check if this integer value
returned was greater than zero so here
greater than zero that's gonna tell us
true if Joe is greater than bill and
false if he's less so we run this and we
get true now let's see if we compare Joe
to Tim okay so T obviously is ahead of J
in the alphabet so we get a value of
false okay and if we get rid of this
greater than zero then we can see
exactly what we're actually getting as a
value so negative ten right because
that's how far away J is from T one
we're comparing them and that's what the
compared T does for us okay
so if we wanted to check if Joe was less
than ten then we check if this value was
less than zero in this case we get true
so that's a really easy way that we can
compare different objects using that
compare to method okay so like this so
public in compare to and you just have
to remember to implement comparable
student and then you can use exactly
this return statement here now the last
thing I want to show is a string
representation of an object so I want to
show you first what happens when I just
want to print out my object to the
screen so I want to print Tim and maybe
ideally I'd like to see like Tim's name
right come
to the screen well look what we get here
we get tutorial one student out and then
all these different letters what this is
printing is actually the memory location
of our object so all of our objects are
actually stored in memory in RAM in like
really fancy ways that I can't really
explain to you guys but anyways this is
like the address for it's like when the
computer looks it up this is what it's
actually using to find Tim and find all
its values and obviously it's telling us
where it is in the tutorial one like
folder file whatever okay so this is no
use to us we this does not help us as
programmers at all we want to see like
something that's a string and gives us
some valuable information so what I need
to do is I need to implement a another
method here that's gonna change this to
a string so we've used this dot two
string before but this is exactly what
I'm going to use brings a public string
and it will say two string like this
okay and what we're gonna do in here is
we're just going to return a string
representation of our object so what we
can do essentially is I can just return
this dot name and this can be what we're
gonna use to represent our object now
typically you might see people do
something like this okay and just follow
me for one second okay they do student
and they have a bracket and we're gonna
add this star name and then they add
that with another bracket so this way
you'll see when I printed it to the
screen what it looks like okay we get
student and then Tim and this is just
simply telling us that the object we're
printing is a type of student and the
name value is Tim okay and we could even
get more fancy and we could add like
double brackets around this dot name if
we want to show that this done name was
a string type okay
now for our purpose I'm just gonna get
rid of this student and this bracket
here and you can see again when we print
this it goes Tim now notice when I'm
printing this I'm not actually calling
this to string method like I'm not not
doing - dot - string that's because Java
actually knows that when we have this to
string method in here this is going to
represent the string right so when we
try to print it it's automatically going
to
that dot two string method okay so now
what we can do is we also just call like
two strings so I can if I wanted to I
could just call dot two string like this
and I could convert a to string and this
will work the exact same way as before
you can see we get Bill okay again in
here you can change this up however
you'd like
in some cases excite your student had
some grades maybe you wanted to write
their name and then after you have like
an array of all their grades or
something like that okay
now inner classes are pretty pretty easy
actually all they are is really just a
class inside of another class or inside
of a method and I'll show you some
examples as we go along but since we
already know all about classes and
methods and static and whatnot I'm not
gonna explain too much of it I'm just
gonna kind of show you how we can create
instances of inner classes in different
ways so I'm gonna start by doing these
incidents outer class here that I've
already created you can see on the side
here I'm just gonna create another class
called inner class right now inner class
is just gonna simply have one method in
it and I'm sure you make this a public
void display and in here all I'm going
to do is simply just display something
to the screen so we know that we're
actually in the right class here okay
now let's say this is an inner class
okay and what's our error here class at
token hmm interesting must have made a
mistakes on my hair one second guys oh
sorry
I'll put these two brackets here hmm
don't know why out of those anyways okay
so this is an inner class now outside of
this class I'm gonna create another
method that's gonna be a part of the
outer class okay so this class is
actually contained within the outer
class meaning that currently since it's
private we can only actually access it
from within our class so if we want to
create an instance of this that means we
must need a method in our class to do
that so in this case I'm gonna say
public void inner and in here we're
going to take nothing and all we're
gonna do is we're gonna create an
instance of our inner class and just
display okay so we're just going to say
in our class I n equals new in your
class like that okay and then all we're
gonna do is just call I end display and
make sure that this is working okay so
now our class is finished we have an
inner class and we have this void inner
and all that does is create an instance
of our inner class and print it to the
screen again note that this is private
meaning we can only access it from
within our our class okay so now if I go
to my main
Java I can run a command so or whatever
creating objects that we can see this so
first of all what I have to do is create
an outer class object so that we can
call that inner class so outer class out
equals new and an outer class now it is
worth noting that I don't have any
constructors here meaning that I don't
need to give any information to my outer
class from my inner class when I first
call it and that's why I can just leave
these blank brackets okay so now if I
want to see my inner class what I have
to do is I have to do out dot inner ok
so we'll call that method to create the
inner class and then run that so let's
run quickly here and we can see we get
this is an inner class awesome so that's
working fine now I'm just gonna make
this public now I'm gonna show you how
we can do this from outside of the class
so right now what we need to do is we
need to create an instance of outer
class and then we need to call the
method inner to be able to create the
inner class and that's because this was
private but now that it's public we
should be able to create an instance of
it outside of the class so the way that
we do that is we still need an instance
of outer class because this class is
defined with an outer class so we need
to first create this so that this is
kind of created right so we did that and
we have outer class now what I can do is
I can say earlier class dot inner class
ok and we just call this one high end
equals lower case equals out which is
going to be our instance of outer class
dot and then in this case we're going to
type inner class believe this is correct
but I guess we'll see oh I probably need
an equal sign and we'll type new new out
inner class and let's see what our
little red line is create class inter
class in package out interesting one
second guys
okay so that's for the issue I knew it
was something like this what we need to
do is we need to do a new and then inter
class because we're creating a new
instance inside of this write-up outer
class of inner class okay so now what
we've done is we've created this I n
which is an object which is a new inner
class so now we can simply use I n which
is an instance of inner class right to
display so now we knew it I on display
okay so if we run this see this is an
inner class and that is working fine so
those are two ways you can gotta access
the inner class now right now you might
be like kay well why the heck would I do
this because now it's just like a ton
more lines well there's many times where
you don't really care about like this
instance and you just want an instance
of the object inside of it so in that
case this would make more sense to do
and obviously you would most likely have
more methods than just one there you
gonna be using okay all right so now
that we have that I guess let's show
creating this kind of inner class stuff
so I'm going to delete this inside of a
method so we can actually create these
inside of methods which are really
useful because sometimes within the
method we want to use a class and we
don't wanna have to define like a new
file for another class okay so we have
this public void inner so I guess let's
just work with this right now you know
we even leave in a class right now I'm
gonna show you how this works so all I
can do in here is I can say I want you
to public you private in this case I'm
just gonna say it I'm gonna just say
class let's see in class inner class and
then here yes that works fine we're just
gonna redefine display so just say
public void display and now that I think
of it I probably could have just copied
on the other code but whatever get some
practice typing println and then in here
again well this should probably be a T
we will just type inner class okay so
this is going to work perfectly fine
whenever we call this void inner then we
have this class inner class we're gonna
create an instance of it and we're going
to display it so if
run this I guess Wow I really should
just kept all that code that's fine why
is this not giving you the auto crash
outer class out because new and out of
class and brackets and then in this case
we'll simply just call out dot inner
okay so now we can see what should
happen is again we should print inner
class so there we go and we get inner
class now pretty much you can do this
like wherever you want
the reason I'm not saying this is public
or private is just because like it's
already within this void so to use it
we're gonna have to call this void so
there's no really there's not really a
point in putting like private or public
but again like if you wanted to could
type public class intercourse or oh
actually saying you can't do that so I
guess I was right the first time so
since it's inside of this void you're
only gonna be able to user when we call
this so there's no route point and
really giving it like a public or
private method or class name sorry
because in here we can still do public
and private methods because we'll
outside of the class we might be using
those methods right so you can see
obviously since I'm creating this
instance inside of the the voids or
inside of inner and if I tried to do
that outside of it it wouldn't work
because this class is only defined when
we call the inner method okay
interfaces are unclear unique to Java
actually because I haven't heard of them
in any other languages but there's
somewhat similar to classes they have to
do with like inheritance and anyways you
guys will see as we go through the video
but they're pretty useful and yeah
they're an important part of Java so we
need to learn them so what we're gonna
do first of all is we're going to create
a new interface now just like we created
a new class we're just gonna right click
on tutorial 1 our package go to new and
instead of class obviously we're gonna
click interface now I'm just going to
name this one vehicle for the example
that I'm going to be doing so I'll click
the vehicle and that's all you need to
do there's no like you don't have to do
package January comments that's fine to
do vehicle alright now we have an
interface called vehicle so what is an
interface well pretty much it is
something that is completely abstract
now this is kind of a new concept but it
means that we're not actually gonna like
do you can't create an instance of an
interface all it's meant to do is to be
inherited from so if we have a class
like car for example that I've created
here car could implement the interface
and use it but we're never gonna create
an instance of an interface it's just
here so that we can implement it in two
different classes hope that makes sense
so inside of our interfaces and you'll
see in a second we can only have public
methods and we actually don't define
anything inside the methods or the the
attributes so when I create a method in
an interface and I'll just make one now
I guess I'm gonna do let's see here Boyd
speed up and we'll take as a prouder in
today that's all I do when I create a
method I don't put those the brackets I
don't do anything inside the method I
just create this now you can see that
this is completely abstract because it
doesn't actually do anything it just
defines the fact that this method exists
so similar to when you create a variable
and you don't give it a value that's
kind of what we're doing here because
we're gonna use this in our car class
and you I kind of have to go through all
of it before you're really gonna
understand but when you create a method
just know that you don't give it any
content all you do is just say like this
method will exist in any of the classes
that implement
okay so I'm gonna create a few methods
here and what do you call it like a
attribute and then we'll just move into
actually using the interface guys
easiest way to understand it so I'm
going to say we have speed up we're
gonna slow down and we'll have let's go
change gear as well just doing a classic
example that we're gonna implement a
vehicle from a car and you guys will see
what I mean something okay
change gear okay and then I'm gonna add
a attribute now any attributes that I
add in here like variables whatever you
guys want to call them they have to be
final now I'm not sure if you remember
in the last video but final means that
it's a constant and it cannot change
okay like we can't change this value so
I'm gonna say final int a equals and
then let's just say five okay actually
or let's just go gears okay like file
into gear each equals five saying that
each thing we're using is gonna have
five gears now watch if I try to just do
into gear is equals five and that still
works but it's not gonna work in the way
that we want okay so just make sure
whatever you're doing this you make them
final if you want to have like variables
or whatever that you want to use in all
of the different classes they must be
final okay
so right now we've defined three methods
and we have one attribute which is just
called github ace now and how does that
how does that work well the way we use
it is we type implements and you might
have seen this before and then the name
of the interface in this case vehicle
okay you can see already that we're
getting a red line we're getting an
error so there's nothing wrong here
because we can implement it but car is
saying the car type car must implement
the inherited abstract method okay so
that means that since we've defined
these three methods here inside of our
interface of vehicle we have to define
them inside our car class so whatever
methods we put here if we implement one
of the interfaces we have to define them
because right now they're completely
abstract and if we call them what we
have no idea what to do because there's
no content for them right so we're gonna
have to create a void we just change
gears I'm gonna say public void change
what did I call gears or gear let's see
change gear okay so change gear and then
it's gonna have to take one parameter in
this case we're gonna say int gear so
like what gear do we want to change to
okay and then we're just gonna go up
here and we're just going to say
privates into gear because we're going
to define that when we when we change
gears all right okay so now we're gonna
go to and make another the other one
that we need so let's just check here we
need to speed up so say public Floyd
speed up and in here we'll have int
speed as like what speed or actually not
speed we're gonna go int change so how
much we're gonna speed up by and then
we'll do one more so public Boyd
slow down like this and again we need
this change and there we go
so this now we're getting no errors
because we've implemented all of the
methods that were abstract over here
okay now gears we don't need to do
anything with it it's just like if we
wanted to use it we could okay so what
I'm gonna do now is inside I'm actually
gonna create another private int I'm
gonna call this speed okay what I'm
gonna do now is I'm going to just just
fill up these uh way decode these method
so I'm gonna say when we changed here
we're just gonna say this dot here
equals whatever gear we're changing it
to and then for speed up gonna say this
speed actually plus equals change okay
and then down here we'll say this does
speed minus equals change game change
perfect okay so now what we're gonna do
is we're actually gonna add one more
method just to show how this works so
we've implemented the things we need to
implement from our interface and now
what we're gonna do is we are going to
just create another method so in this
case I'm gonna make this like a display
method so that we can display our car
pretty easy okay so public void display
and inside of here I'm just gonna print
out a few things the screen so system
dot out dot println and in this case
we'll just say I am a car comma and then
we'll just add actually looks like going
and how fast we going we're going this
speed and if we wanted to get out like a
little km/h so let's do that and I am in
gear and we'll just add whatever the
dearest so this ducks this dog gear
perfect okay so let's now actually use
this so we have our interface vehicle
okay and we have our car so what we're
gonna do now is gonna create car objects
will say car I don't know let's say Ford
okay equals new car okay perfect
and now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna say car dot forward I guess is
what we need to do we'll say a Ford
speed up and let's maybe change it to 10
lat
10 to it and I just realized that we're
actually gonna have to make this speed
default I like zero gears let's just do
that default zero as well Lois we're
gonna run into an error um actually gear
I guess you can't really be in gear zero
can you let's change that to 1 okay
perfect okay so for don't speed up and I
will say Ford done change gear and let's
just change the gear to okay and then if
we want to display our Ford we give you
four dot display perfect okay so let's
run this now and see if everything's
working so we say I'm a car going ten
kilometers an hour and I am in gear to
perfect so that's working fine and we've
implemented all that stuff from our
interface vehicle interface so now I'm
going to show you some cool things we
can add into our interfaces that make
them a lot more useful so say for
example you've used a bunch of
interfaces with a bunch of classes
you've inherited from them and now what
you want to do is you want to add a
method to all of those classes that are
inherited from it well what you could do
is if you do the same thing here and you
could type something like this and then
you could go into every single one of
your classes and you could change them
to be whatever you want but if you want
the method to be the same for all of
them we can actually use something this
is why interfaces are kind of useful
called default okay so if we type
default and then maybe in this case void
and let's just say like out like we're
gonna print something out just make it
easy what we'll do here is we'll just we
can just create a method and we can
use this from any of the classes that
inherits our our interface okay so I'll
do here is I'll say system dot out dot
println in this case I'll just say
default method okay
I'm very creative how did I you spell
system and I okay anyways alright I'm
tagged guys I apologize system dot out
dot println default method ok so now
that we have that from within this car
class we can use that default method so
say when we display we want to print
that and then we want to do the default
what we could do believe is we can say
just out maybe and yes that actually
works fine so now that we have because
that is a method within our vehicle
class and we implemented let's see what
happens when we run our program we get I
am a car going ten kilometers an hour
and I am gear to and then says default
method it's using that default method
that we created inside of our interface
now I believe we can actually use static
methods as well so this would be known
as something that's not a static method
because we have to call it from within
our our class but we can actually create
static methods within our interface that
we can then just call statically like we
don't have to have an instance to call
them so if you don't know what I mean
just follow along for a second as I'm
you're doing just create a static I
don't know let's just do like int let's
return some of us change it up let's
just call this math I feel like math is
a keyword and that's fine we'll just do
math okay we're gonna take int B and all
we're gonna do is we're gonna return
b-plus not okay I don't very basic but
that's all we're gonna do just to prove
a point so now say I'm in my main job
alright and we get rid of this we don't
create a car object and I want to use
this static method inside of my
interface well what I can do is I can do
vehicle dot and then you can see it
already has this function coming up or
this method dot math give it a value
like five I'm just actually set this
equal to a variable say index
equals that and then we can system dot
out that and see what we're actually
getting as a value in this case we
should be getting 14 right yeah so 14
there we go
so that's so you can create a static
method inside of your interface so in
some cases you can kind of think of
these as functions all right say you had
and I should you know I'll just do one
as an example because this is kind of
useful
I go new interface and we call this math
okay then inside here you could do a
bunch of static methods that will do
like math operations for you like maybe
you have the quadratic formula maybe you
had um I don't know like Euclidean
distance so yeah I don't know a bunch of
different math formulas you put them all
in this math interface and then way you
want to access them it would come in
here and you'd say well math dot maybe
like square root like sq RT okay and
then there you'd be able to use all of
those I want to call functions but
they're really methods inside the the
interface really easily so that is a
really good example of when you can kind
of use interfaces
now enums are pretty much a collection
of constants that we can reference and
then we can do things with those
constants and they are pretty cool and
just make your code more readable and
yeah you guys will see why don't we go
through the video so the first step is
to create an enum now to do that is
similar to creating a class or an
interface or whatever go to your package
right click it click new and then enum
so for you know I'm just gonna name mine
hmm actually I'm just gonna name my
level because you'll see why it just
makes sense for this example so again
the syntax here is public enum level
rather than like class or interface or
whatever right so in here is where we're
gonna define our constants okay now this
is really useful because we don't have
to do like public static int whatever
like the name like we can literally just
type whatever value we want our constant
to be and typically it's a string so in
my case I'm gonna go for level I'm gonna
go in all caps you don't have to go in
all caps when you go high medium and low
okay now these are the three constants
on this store in my level Eitam so we
have high medium low and yeah that's
literally all I'm gonna do right now for
my enum it just means we have three
constants that we can reference from
level and these the three and obviously
you could do as many as you want and
just keep going with commas on and I
think you can put them on the same line
as well it just makes it more readable
if you do them on like other lines okay
so we have three constants now I'm going
to show you how we can actually use this
enum and you'll start to understand how
it works so to use this enum we have to
create a new instance of it so to do
this I'm going to say the level and
we'll just say lvl equals new actually I
think it's like this it was level dot
and yeah so we say high low and medium
so my case will just pick a low and I'll
put a semicolon and now you can see it's
all showing up in different colors and
this is where could find so now that we
have this as a constant we can do
certain things with it right so
typically you might want to check what
value your constant is so like what
value is level so we can obviously use
these in an if statement I like so so if
I said if lvl equals equals and they're
like it's the level dot and it'll start
out low I guess
and we'll just work our way up to high
and we'd say L if our else--if and we'll
say lvl equals equals and then level dot
and medium ok we'll do something in
there and then finally else because if
it's not a lower medium it must be high
then we'll just use me here so in this
case we'll just say system dot out dot
println and we're gonna print level for
all of them because I want to show what
this does okay oh what the heck did I
just do there okay anyways wait now
we're just printing a level each time
and actually we just run this down and
see what happens so you see we get low
so when we print out level it's simply
just gonna print like whatever the
constant is that we have and that's
because it has a go to string method
built-in so we can convert these into
this string and I'll show you what I
mean by that so pretty much say we
wanted to get this because right now
like it's not a string it's not an int
it's not a boolean we don't really know
what type it is it's just like in level
it gets an enum so to actually get this
as a string value if we wanted to do
something with it or store it we can use
dot to string so if I say string I will
say II yen why not why not we'll say is
equal to lv l dot to string and that's
just going to convert this to a string
for us and then we can do all our string
operations or whatnot with that alright
so let's say get it to a string now
another really useful thing with enums
is we can actually get all the different
values of enums and print that to the
screen so how do you system dot out dot
println and I believe the way we do this
is the level dot values yes there we are
so we go level dot values and if we hit
that where we type that in you're gonna
see when we run this now it gives us
well it is actually giving us an array
with the values so when we try to print
that we're getting like you know the
memory address of it so once we have
these values so make sure you're just
gonna store this in an array so that we
can then iterate through it and print
them out what I'm gonna do is I'll say
level array and this is the way you have
to do it I will say ARR is equal to and
then level of thought values okay so
that's working fine so what we're gonna
do now is which is create a quick for
loop so and I'll show you how we can
loop
through all the different values so say
for e1 which would be s level level e
and then we'll say in ARR what we'll do
is we'll simply just print out e okay
so system I print out e and then we can
see all the different constants that
we're gonna get so let's go here and you
see we get high medium low and then just
print slow again just cuz we're doing
the Selective statement here okay and
that's how you can loop through all the
different values so that's really cool
but you might say okay well that's cool
Tim but is this really that useful like
we just have these constants well
there's a few other things that we can
do inside of this you know add some
methods and some instructors as well so
that these constants actually point to
certain values kind of similar to like a
hash table or hash map that I showed you
before so the way that we can do that is
we need to create first of all a
variable that's gonna be private so in
this case I'm gonna say private and I'll
say actually int level lvl Dom okay so
this is gonna just be a private value
that's just gonna store the value of
each of these so like low medium high
the value of all these levels so to set
this value what we need to do is you
need to create a constructor for our
edom and you'll see how this works in a
second so I'm just gonna say public
level inch and then num okay and in here
which it what are we getting here remove
invalid modifiers legal modifier freedom
cute right only private discriminate
just do this private sorry my bad
private because we're just gonna call it
on here you'll see in a second private
level into them and then we're just
gonna say this dot lvo num is equal to
num okay there we go so now what I can
actually do is you see how these are
highlighting it red so since this is a
private constructor that means we're
gonna define this variable based on what
constant we choose for the enum so I'm
gonna put brackets here and I'm going to
define high as three medium as two and
low as one now what this is gonna do is
it's gonna keep our same constants of
high medium and low but when we create a
new constant it's gonna
activate this constructor of level and
it's gonna set this level num equal to
whatever value we put in the bracket
search so in this case three two one
we could obviously have multiple what
you call parameters here and we can have
multiple arguments here and we have a
ton of different values and yeah so the
only issue is since this value is
private we're gonna need a way to access
it from our main here because that's
probably what we're gonna want to use it
so that means we're gonna have to create
a few methods too well change that level
num and to get that level them so we've
done this before but actually I don't
think I can do a public and we'll see if
we can public gets level and then in
here we'll simply return yes this is
gonna need to be an int public into get
level will simply return this LVL num
okay yeah so that does work fine I just
can't do a public constructor okay so
this is just gonna give us the level num
if we call get level on our you know
okay not to change this I what he call
it level num what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to do sex lvl and instead of
having interior just gonna be a void
okay and all we're gonna say is this
thought allele none is equal to num and
then we're gonna put in here int num
okay perfect so now what we're doing is
we have a way to not only get the level
num but to change it so now let's try
using this out in our main and see how
this works so I'm just gonna get rid of
all this stuff cuz we don't need this
for right now so right now we have our
level and it's level dot low so to
actually get the value of this level we
can use something called get value of or
we can use that method that we had here
so in this case I'm going to say get
level so what I'll do is I'll say system
dot out dot println and in here we'll
say lvl dot and then what was the thing
we were using get level like this so now
if we print this out to the screen we
should be getting one and indeed we are
we're getting one so now I want to show
you this thing it's called get value of
okay and is it its value ever get value
if I'm not sure we'll see so I'm pretty
sure if we do something like this level
dot value of yes
that's exactly what it is and then we
pick we type in whatever the enum is so
in this case we could say hello it's
gonna give us let's see what's the issue
here okay yeah so the issues I just got
to put this in string I just forgot
about that so I do the level dot get
value of and say I put a string in here
so like say someone was typing in and
into the computer and they type in a
string rain you want to pass this in to
get value if you see what's we're
actually gonna get is we get low right
because that is the value of this string
in enum although it's not a string it
can like determine that okay so that's
what value of is used for I can't really
give you any good examples of them
because I really know any good examples
of using value of but for any of you
that might see some use in it I figured
I would show it to you so I guess we can
do an example now just setting the level
just to make sure that all of that is
working
I say lvl dot set level in this case
let's say five and then let's just grab
this again actually and we can delete
this from up here and now I'm just
simply going to print out would go lvl
dot yeah level and just make sure that
everything is changing and working fine
and there we go we get the level of five
so that is how we can use items pretty
much they're used for when you want to
have a collection of different constants
maybe you want to loop through see what
those constants are and it just makes a
code kind of readable records we have
level dot low and then that low can
point to like five to one whatever and
that's all stored within our enum right
here obviously you can have as many
enums as you want and you'll really see
the use of them further on in java but
when you're creating like larger
programs okay so anyways that has been
it for this video if you guys enjoyed
please make sure you leave a like and
subscribe and I will see you again in
another video